hoffentlich gibt es heute qualitätsoptionen twitch please qualitätsoptionen
oh nice ich habe qualitätsoptionen instant easy instant quality options
jetzt schreckt perfekt ich glaube heute posten wir das mal auf twitter das haben sich die
letzten mal so viele leute wieder beschwert macht sich kriegt das überhaupt nicht mit dass du am
streben sonn bist und der eine hat sogar geschrieben max kannst du deine streams nicht auf youtube
hochladen da muss ich sagen nee das ist das passt da auch nicht hin ich versuche euch jetzt mal
zu hypnotisieren mit lull 4d vielleicht hilft das ja ich sehe das gerade in meiner von meinem
vorschau fenster das sieht unglaublich bescheuert aus das sieht unglaublich dumm aus in vorschau
wie es darum springt ist bei euch die lull 4d animation flüssig in meiner vorschau ruckel die
das sieht in der vorschau mega bescheuert aus ich kann es euch leider nicht zeigen ich glaube
das liegt am gif ich glaube das gif ruckelt ja ja ja so ist glaube das gif ruckelt ruckelt
der hier auch ach du schein okay das ist das zu viel des guten und das ist das das ist übelst
hypnotisch leute ihr müsst mal versuchen versucht den mal pass mal auf guckt mal hier hin versucht
ihm mal zwischen die augen zu gucken ja guckt das guckt euch das an also geht jetzt mal vor
eurem bildschirm setzt euch so davor dass ihr genau hier monka es zwischen die augen gucken
könnt und jetzt und jetzt versucht mal das weiterhin zu machen alter das übelst da hat
er nur noch ein auge wenn man das versucht ne habt ihr das auch dann verschwimmt das
alles zu einem auge das ist ja illuminati ne das kann ich nicht weitermachen verfolgt
so liegt was ich wusste gar nicht dass heute liegt liegt auf legends sind ich habe keine
ahnung von loll wirklich null ahnung ich bin der größte loll noob überhaupt den es gibt
wo haben wir eigentlich unsere unsere text zu speech falls wir die zwischendrinne brauchen
eu rasiert gerade china ist das wie sagt man so ist ist das was herausrag also wie ist das
sowieso die verteilung in loll ich habe so keine ahnung davon ja das da meinst du das
sind koreaner ane die haben verloren ich kenne auch nicht mal die teams ich kenne nur die
weil die hatten auch mal einen starcraft team ansonsten kenne ich mich mit loll worlds und
sowas die kenne ich auch gut sie nein kennt man für netik kennt man edward gaming habe
ich noch nie gehört aber ich vermute mal dass das was herausragend ist wenn du sagst
dass eu gerade china rasiert rasiert zu dem thema fällt mir gerade ein kennt noch jemand
geland ab die das ist ja auch komplett wieder das war mal so das fünf minuten miem schlechthin
ja jeder jeder hat versucht zu reden wie geland ab die und dann ist wieder vorbei gewesen
und heute denken sich alle wenn man sagt geland ab die wirst das denn loll ist vor zwei jahren
schon gestorben also da muss ich leider widersprechen nämlich jetzt nehme ich mal hier kurz auf
twitch gucken und uns mal anschauen was die meist gespielten games sehr gut jetzt ist
natürlich blöde rolls sind aber man muss sagen ein spiel was knapp eine millionen zuschauer
hat ganz knapp und das nur oft wird das kann schlecht gestorben sein da wirst du mir wahrscheinlich
recht geben oder für dich ja für dich das ist wieder was anderes was mich ja wirklich
wundert ist ich laber jetzt mal ein bisschen rum bis die mal bis alle gecheckt haben dass
das viel life ist was mich ja wundert ist wie gut sich black ops vier hält ich wollte
übrigens noch auf twitter auf twitter posten wie gut sich black ops vier hält es hält
sich deutlich besser als die letzten call of duty aber die letzten call of duty sind auch
kein battle royale das hält sich sogar so gut dass ich tatsächlich noch wann kam es
raus eine woche zwei wochen immer noch ab und zu call of duty spiele ich habe so ein paar
ganz gute gameplays ich könnte sogar absolut videos hochladen könnte ich rein vom gameplay
material her machen wir mal tweet tweet twitch mit der
tipp Somerset
Okay, gut.
Moin Max, ich schau dich schon lange, was, Moment, ich kann, ich kann nicht lesen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, es ist schon früh, aber es ist ja nicht mal früh.
Ähm, langsam.
Also, moin Max.
Ich schau dich, glaube schon, so lange, dass ich nicht mal weiß wie lange schon.
Ich weiß es auch nicht.
Ich kann dir da leider nicht helfen, wenn du mir deinen YouTube-Namen sagst, dann kann
ich gucken wann du schon, wann du abonniert hast.
Das seh ich nämlich.
Gibt's eigentlich noch Programmierend-Streams?
Ja, der letzte Stream war ein Programmierend-Stream.
Und der letzte Stream ist noch nicht so lange her, der letzte Stream war vor vier, fünf
Tagen oder so.
Ich hab ja überlegt, ob ich, ob wir heute Memetool weiter machen, weil ich hab natürlich
schon, also Offstream weiter programmiert, oder ob wir was spielen und irgendwie hatte
ich heute Morgen übelst Bock, ähm, das Vier von 2005 zu spielen, weil es ein ultrageiles
Game ist.
Es ist da eines der besten, ähm, und technisch finde ich auch wegweilsten Games von so aus
dem Dreh 2005 rum und eines der besten Shooter bis heute.
Das ist übelst gut.
Also, also eins, wohlgemerkt.
Vier eins ist gut, der Rest ist absoluter Schrott.
Vier zwei, das konnte man sich gerade noch geben, war aber auch nicht wirklich gut.
Und, ähm, vier, vier drei hab ich gar nicht mehr gespielt und auch die Addons zum ersten
Teil, das allererste Addon ging halbwegs, aber der Rest war nicht gut.
Vier drei, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab vier drei, ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie das aussieht
eigentlich.
Das sieht überhaupt nicht mehr nach Vier aus, das ist überhaupt noch vom gleichen Hersteller.
Nee.
Was ist eigentlich aus Monolith geworden?
Was ist eigentlich aus denen geworden?
Ist ein Blablablablablablablabla.
Ach, waren das die, waren das die auch mit No One Lives Forever?
Nee, das waren noch andere.
Doch.
Und, No One Lives Forever war doch nicht von Monolith, oder?
Ernsthaft?
Doch.
Ha.
Wisste, meiner hat noch was.
Ok, also die gibt's anscheinend immer so wirklich, weil man sich überlegt, ähm, doch anscheinend
gibt's die noch.
Keine Ahnung.
Zumindest haben sie, ähm, nach Vier nichts mehr Gutes rausgebracht, wie's aussieht.
Versteh ich gar nicht warum.
Weil, also No One Lives Forever 1 und 2 war nice, ähm, das kenn ich auch noch, das war
so ein Mech-Game gewesen, das war eigentlich auch ganz gut, Vier 1 war herausragend für
die damalige Zeit, ja, das war so, Vier 1 ist so ein, ähm, so ein Schwanzvergleich-Game
gewesen.
Quasi, wer konnte den Benchmark besser laufen?
Oh, ich guck mal was für Benchmark, ich starte mal, guck mal was für Benchmark-Ergebnisse
kriege.
Und die Musik muss aus.
Wir können bei den Benchmark nämlich gleich mal testen, ob die Lautstärke ok ist.
Huzzle Maul.
So.
Gleich mal gucken, hier müssen wir, Alter, muss man gleich so nen Sound am Anfang machen.
Ähm, sag mir mal wie der Sound ist, ob das zu laut ist, zu leise, zu sonst was, Performance,
Test Settings.
Gucken wir mal, es kann sein, dass ich leise machen muss.
Achja, ok, ich hab FPS-Lok, ich hab V-Sync an, läuft konstant 144 FPS, bisschen laut,
oder?
Bisschen sehr laut, kriegen die ja die Ohren weg, oder ist das nur für mich so laut?
Wobei es geht eigentlich, es wird ja nicht permanent geballert, man läuft ja auch teilweise
sinnlos rum.
Oh, Physik-Engine, Pogas, oh Gott, das ist, das ist definitiv zu laut, äh, Hypermonka-S.
Ok, back, leider müssen wir heute, oh wir müssen nicht ohne, aber meine Horts, meine
Shortcuts gehen nicht, das Game crappt meine Shortcuts, ich kann also quasi mein Meme-Tool
nur mit Web-Interface bedienen, aber ich finde es interessant, dass es funktioniert.
Also wir werden noch wahrscheinlich ganz oft Monka-S brauchen, Sound ist ok, dann legen
wir mal los.
Also vielleicht noch ein paar Worte zu dem Game, bevor es losgeht, und zwar, das Game
ist glaube ich von 2005, von Ende 2005, also das Game ist über 10 Jahre alt, und man muss
sagen, ihr habt ja gerade die Grafikdemo gesehen, hast du schon World War 2 gespielt, du meinst
World War 3, oder?
Das läuft leider nicht, ich hab's, ich hab's mir gekauft, auf Steam, aber es geht nicht,
weil die Server kaputt sind, und bevor ich jetzt quasi den ganzen Tag warte auf Server,
hab ich mir gedacht, spielen wir mal eine Runde 4 durch.
Ja, 4-1 ist absolut Pogjam, 2 oder, nein, Release the Beast ist Kraygasm, das ist kein
Pogjam, das ist quasi noch, noch besser.
Ach, GIFs absp... doch, geht immer noch, nice, ja, also das Game ist von 2005, und man hat
es aber gerade schon gesehen, das ist relativ gut gealtert, das liegt aber auch daran, das
Game war zu seiner Zeit grafisch wirklich Spanzvergleich tauglich, also wenn man einen Rechner hatte,
der das Game, ähm, quasi auf diesem Detail hervorgeht, wie ich es hier heute easy laufen
lassen kann, ja, ähm, damals spielen konnte, der hat echt den längsten gehabt, ähm, was,
was, was für ein Programm hat denn das Lambda-Zeichen unter der Tastleiste, das kann ich kurz noch
mal zeigen, das ist ein Terminal, das ist CMD-er, das ist ein Terminal, das ist quasi ein Ersatz
für CMD, mit dem Unterschied, dass CMD absolut sackt und CMD ja eigentlich ganz gut bedienbar
ist.
Hat auch, hat auch viele Optionen, also bietet sich an, wo wir gerade dabei sind, als Paketverwaltung
empfehle ich dann nebenbei noch Scoop zu installieren, dann hat man ein bisschen was, äh, von, von
dem, wie angenehm es unter Linux ist, auch unter Windows.
Der Stil in Half-Life 2 ist sehr ähnlich, ja, aber Half-Life 2 kam doch erst später, oder?
Kam Half-Life 2 nicht später?
Was?
Half-Life 2 kam vor 4?
Jetzt bin ich aber überrascht.
Ja, tatsächlich, ähm, aber, ähm, es hat halt einen anderen Stil, aber es sah grafisch
bei, das riecht gut aus, und eine Sache, was ich finde, was bis heute fast unerreicht ist,
ist, ähm, die KI.
Klar, ich mein, du kannst heute mit der aktuellen CPU-Power deutlich mehr machen, aber die KI
in dem Game ist wirklich gut, das werdet ihr jetzt zwischenzeitlich sehen, ich muss noch
kurz ausmachen und wieder an, lasst ihr auch alles speichern, weil das backt sonst ein
bisschen rum.
Die KI ist wirklich extrem gut, also, ähm, wenn man gegen so einen Squad von 3-4 Gegnern
am Start ist, die sind teilweise so clever, dass die um die Ecke laufen, in die Richtung,
wo du jetzt nicht denkst, dass sie laufen, warten und wenn sie dich hören, dass du rumgelaufen
bist, von hinten auf dich schießen, die KI ist wirklich nicht blöd.
Gibt's 4.1 nicht auf Steam? Nein, leider nicht, 4.1 ist indiziert oder, oder was auch immer
genau in Deutschland, keine Ahnung, ähm, aber GOG darf's irgendwie verkaufen.
Ja, genau, das ist indiziert und die hatten, die haben halt gesagt, wir machen keine abgespeckte
Version mit Robotern oder grünem Blut oder so, weil man muss sagen, dass es halt gegen
Menschen ist und dass es halt auch ein bisschen splattert ist Teil des Games, ja, sonst, sonst
hätte man, sonst hätte man in dem Game einfach auch kein Schiss.
Es gab, es gab es glaube ich mal auf Steam, Knäherbär, ja, jedem das eine, jeder was
er will.
So, ähm, wir fangen an, ich halte am Anfang die Klappe, es kommt ein bisschen Story Sequenz,
falls es zu laut sein sollte, sag Bescheid, dann war ich ein bisschen leiser und ich hab
das Game zuletzt gespielt vor wahrscheinlich 10 Jahren oder so und ich kann mich noch,
wir haben übrigens einen Mod, wir haben einen Mod, was ein paar Sachen ändert, wir haben
einen Mod, der, der, der, ähm, was macht denn der Mod eigentlich, genau alles, also
er macht auf jeden Fall die Bluteffekte ein bisschen anders, hat glaube ich die Waffen
ein bisschen modifiziert und irgendwie sowas, aber, ähm, wenn man sich die Kommentare
durchliest macht der Mod das Spiel eigentlich im Prinzip nur besser und, also wie gesagt
ich hab's das letzte Mal vor 10 Jahren gespielt und ich hab, ich hab übel Schiss bei dem Game
gehabt.
Das ist, das Game, das schafft's wirklich ganz gut, wir spielen auch mal auf High Difficulty,
wenn schon, man kann sich die Option immer noch, noch, noch ändern, man muss sagen,
das, ähm, ist eines der wenigen Spiele, wirklich eines, es gibt nicht viele Spiele, wo ich
wirklich Schiss dabei hatte, aber die haben das hingekriegt, wahrscheinlich weil es so
eine gute Abwechslung zwischen, zwischen Splatter, Geballer und, ähm, erschrecken ist, keine
Ahnung.
So, auf geht's.
Riesenschrift, und ich wette mit euch, der Name des Spiels war da, bevor sie auf die Idee
gekommen sind, dass die Spezialeinheit ja zufällig First Encounter Assault Recon heißen könnte,
aber man hat eine coole Abkürzung.
Warner Brother Games, gibt's die überhaupt, da sind die mit Batman, oder?
Wo sind die jetzt mit Batman?
Mit, mit Arkham Asylum und so?
Egal, ich halt mal die Klappe für das Intro.
Out
Stack, ok?
Ah, ah, ah!
Das weißt du ja auch warum das initiiert war in Deutschland.
Ja?
Tut mir leid, Senator. Es geht um Origen.
Was ist passiert?
Es war eine Überraschung. Vettel hat die Prototypen in Hand genommen.
Mein Gott...
Wir können es uns immer noch diskret lösen, aber wir müssen schnell los.
Alles klar, alles klar. Ich mache ein paar Anrufe.
Das Name dieses Wackos ist Paxton Vettel. Er ist der Schlüssel.
Wenn wir ihn enthalten, enthalten wir die Situation.
Fucker hat einen Hunger.
Ich denke, er hat eine Agenda. Es ist nicht nur rekreationell. Er bekommt etwas aus der Agenda.
Essential Vitamins und Nutriente?
Was ist seine Geschichte?
Er ist von Armikam Technologie Corporation. Sie arbeiten an einem Militärkontrakt, um eine Armee von Klonen zu entwickeln, die zu einem psychischen Kommandanten reagieren.
Top secret, natürlich. Vettel ist einer der Kommandanten.
Ihr müsst mich nicht fokussieren. Das ist das, warum niemand uns mit Militärklonen ernst nimmt.
Ein voller Battalion von ihnen, hoch trainiert und schwer armiert.
Ein Battalion? Was sollen wir gegen 1.000 Super Soldaten tun?
Wie gesagt, wir legen Vettel runter und es ist vorbei. Leider ist das Ziel des Programms, den Kommandanten in den Wettbewerb zu kennen.
Das Witzige ist, wollte ich mal kurz sagen, das ist eines der wenigen Games, die versuchen zu erklären, wo die Gegner herkommen.
Warum auch immer die Regierung Klonensoldaten hat?
Ich lasse ich jetzt mal dahingestellt.
Das bedeutet, wir sollten den Bastard kontern, ohne durch all die Soldaten zu warten.
Wie finden wir ihn?
Er hat einen Transmitter in der Kopf geplant. Er sollte uns direkt zu ihm führen.
Das ist sehr komfortabel.
Ich glaube, er tut das, was er soll.
Was ist mit dir, Kumpel? Bist du bereit, zu arbeiten?
Du hast ihn in den Feld gesetzt?
Bist du verrückt? Er hat ihn vor einer Woche transferiert.
Du hast seine Trainungsresultate gesehen. Seine Reflexe sind völlig auf den Plätzen. Ich denke, er kann sich selbst handeln.
Was auch immer, Mann. Es ist dein Call.
Verdammt richtig, es ist.
Keine Sorge. Du wirst gut sein.
Lasst uns los.
Und wie fein wir sein werden.
Was ist das erste Mal, dass du dich erinnerst?
Wo hast du ihn genommen?
Du wirst ein Gott unter einem Mann sein.
Okay.
Wir haben Fettel zu einem verlassenen Gebäude vorgebracht.
Kein Zeichen der Gegneraktivität auf dem Satelliten.
Aber nimm keine Chancen.
Jenkowski, bist du in Position?
Nimm nur die Worte.
Okay, los.
Ich kann nicht springen. Warum kann ich nicht springen?
Moment.
Jump.
Ja, anders sein. Best default setting ever.
Wer will schon springen in dem Game?
Ich bin gebadet, outdated.
Guckt euch mal an hier.
Dieser nice Flimmer.
Seht ihr das drumherum so? Feuer.
Da haben sie sich damals echt Mühe gegeben.
Ach ja, und für alle Max Payne-Fans.
Bullet-Time.
Wo ist die Ratte hin?
Hier.
Die versuchen sogar in dem Game Bullet-Time zu erklären,
mit dass man so übermenschlich geile Reflexe hat.
Max Payne spielen wir auch noch mal im Game.
Das muss ich mir aufschreiben. Ich habe mir nämlich eine Liste gemacht.
Von Games,
die ich alle mal im Stream spielen will.
Wollt ihr mal wissen?
Ich habe mir nämlich gedacht, wir könnten mal so eine Klassiker-Woche machen,
wo ich nur Sachen spiele, die ich geil finde.
Habe ich auf High gestellt?
Difficult. Ja, nice.
Geh auf.
Peter ist alarmiert.
Anzeige ist raus.
Anzeige ist raus wie Blinde.
Wonka Shake.
Alter, das Game.
Wenn das so lange her ist, dass ich es zuletzt gespielt habe,
ich kann mich auch nicht mal so richtig gut dran erinnern.
Da liegt Fleisch rum.
Oder sowas.
NAM aufs Schloss.
Alter, soll ich mich rollen oder was?
Jetzt geht er ab.
Die Lampe muss gekickt werden.
Let's go.
Ey, ich look around.
Oh.
Haben wir die runter?
Hättest du auch Lust, das erste Crysis zu spielen?
Machen wir alles.
Und zwar, ich habe mir jetzt überlegt, ich hoffe, ich kann jetzt mal kurz was sagen,
bevor wieder Zeug passiert.
Was war der Name von dem Grill nochmal?
Alma.
Und zwar habe ich mir überlegt, was mir so spontan eingefallen ist,
was man alles mal spielen könnte, kampagnenmäßig.
Battlefield Bad Company 1, Bad Company 2, Titanfall 2, Battlefield 3, Battlefield 4,
COD 4, Spec Ops The Line könnten wir spielen.
Auch von der Story her ein gutes Game.
Zwar ein bisschen deprimierend.
Soldier So Fortune 2, auch eines der geilsten Games ever.
Hier weiß ich, ich halte jetzt die Klappe, weil es jetzt...
Schreckt, da konnte ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Der Max ist ziemlich angespannt.
Ich habe den großen Vorteil, ich weiß nicht wie es bei euch aussieht,
ob ihr das Game überhaupt kennt, das ist ja schon ein bisschen her,
dass ich mich noch so grob dran erinnern kann.
Ich wusste, dass der Typ jetzt um die Ecke kommt.
Ich muss mal was ausprobieren.
Passiert nichts, okay.
Das war noch vor sie verlassen das Schlachtfeld.
Alles klar.
Auf geht's.
Hast du die Erweiterung?
Ja, habe ich.
Ich habe auf GOG die Dings gekauft, die All-Inclusive.
Aber die zweite Erweiterung fand ich nicht gut, die erste ging.
Das war damals absolut geile Grafik, das ist 2005.
Damals hast du gedacht, das sieht geil aus.
Und ich kann euch eins sagen, die Goreffekte auch schon in dem normalen Game,
das war echt nicht ohne.
Da werden eigentlich nur von solchen auf Fortune 2 getoppt,
was das Game jetzt eigentlich mit den besten Goreffekten, ever.
Also ich habe übrigens keine Frametrops.
Das ist ein Game, was mal wieder der Meinung ist,
es muss automatisch Checkpoints anlegen.
So, wir müssen die Tür aufmachen.
Easy.
Gibt nicht so viel.
Das Schöne war, damals war Open Word noch überhaupt nicht angesagt.
Da gab es ein, zwei Wege, wo man lang kann, der Rest ist dicht.
Alter.
Smoke.
Hallo.
Alter, warum ist das so dick?
Man konnte doch irgendwie springen und geilen.
Genau.
Wie ging das?
Rennen und...
Okay, darf man nicht durch.
Ich kann nämlich so komische Jump Moves machen.
Was geht denn mit dem?
Das Game ist aus einer Zeit, wo es voll angesagt war,
dass man Horror vor kleinen Mädchen hatte.
Habt ihr noch mehr?
Gab es ja auch jede Menge Filme in der Richtung.
10-0.
Was die halt echt geil im ersten Teil gemacht haben,
was im zweiten Teil verloren gegangen ist,
dass halt nicht jedes Mal, weil man erschreckt wurde,
es was Gefährliches war.
Zum Beispiel, dass das Licht jetzt hier flimmert
oder dass irgendwo was runterfällt.
Das haben sie im zweiten Teil war zu viel.
Jetzt wird gebashed.
Ich kann dir leider nicht helfen.
Die können noch nichts.
Weil ich total beknackt habe, dass ich das jetzt angeschossen habe.
Haben wir hier irgendwas?
Health oder so?
Irgendwas?
Ich bin nämlich nicht sicher.
Ich brauche mal ein Health Pack.
Ich brauche kein Health Pack.
Das kommt nämlich auch noch aus einer Zeit,
wo nichts mit Auto Heal war.
Ich habe es in dem Game schon Collectibles.
Nicht wirklich.
Es gibt so Booster.
Ich habe am Anfang so einen Booster aufgenommen.
Von dem einen Booster kriegt man mehr Leben.
Von dem anderen kriegt man mehr Bullet Time.
Aber das sind keine Collectibles in dem Sinn,
wie Dog Tags oder sonst was.
Es gibt natürlich die typische Story-Geschichte,
die alle Horror Games haben.
Die Story wird zum Teil über irgendwelche Anrufbeantworter
und Dinger erzählt.
Das war damals noch nicht ausgelutscht,
sondern das war eines der ersten Games, die das gemacht haben.
Physik funktioniert schon mal.
Die Waffe ist irgendwie aus dem Mod.
Die nehmen wir nicht.
Die ist OP.
Die hat 7.900, 8.000 Schuss.
Die nehmen wir nicht. Die ist OP.
Wobei wir spielen auf High.
Vielleicht brauchen wir es ab und zu mal.
Das Game hat auch keine Skins oder Lootboxen oder sowas.
Dafür hat das Game...
Die krassesten Media-Animationen, die ich je gesehen habe,
kann Battlefield 1 einpacken.
In welcher Engine wurde das gemacht?
Wie hieß denn das?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie die hieß.
Das ist nichts, was man kennt.
Das war was von...
Ich sollte den übrigens gerade Mehlertöten fällt mir ein.
Hab ich aber nicht.
Weil ich so spät auf den Text geachtet habe.
Da war was.
Man muss sagen, die Gegner sind echt clever in dem Game.
Und die machen in High, und wir spielen auf High, ziemlich viel Damage.
Fuck.
Ja, move in.
Fertig in, gemove.
Boah, es geht mir dem.
Und das fand ich damals übertrieben beeindruckend,
dass die an Wänden und so Einschusslöcher machen konnten.
Also, fuck.
Wo ist er?
Zum Glück habe ich einen Helzpack.
Hab ich auch die richtige Schwierigkeit,
nicht, dass ich jetzt hier auf Easy spiele oder so?
Das wollen wir ja nicht.
Nee, habe ich.
Ja, irgendwie so genau hieß das.
Das ist so eine Engine, die kennt man noch aus dem ein oder anderen Game,
aber das ist jetzt nichts vom Kaliber Unreal, CryEngine oder...
Was ist das Dritte?
Äh, Unity.
So, ein bisschen gucken müssen wir, dass wir Helzbooster und Bullet-Time Booster haben.
Ihr könnt Bullet-Time Booster nicht übersehen.
Ich habe zu viel Cod gespielt, merkt ihr das?
Ich springe um Ecken, ich jumpshotte um Ecken.
Übrigens, ich habe mal einen Speedrun zu dem Game gesehen,
das sieht ungefähr so aus.
Irgendwie so, ganz merkwürdig, aber nicht so lahm,
die können das irgendwie schneller.
4-3 habe ich nicht gespielt.
Ich fand den zweiten schon immer so gut.
Und auch eines der ersten Games mit so richtig coolen Licht- und Schatten-Dingern.
Half-Life 2 hatte das ja auch.
Aber so viel Abstand ist zwischen den Games ja nicht.
Jaja, ich spiele immer noch Black Ops.
Irgendwie habe ich in Erinnerung, dass sich die Bullet-Time nicht auflädt.
Oder?
Hat sich die Bullet-Time schon immer wieder aufgeladen?
Oder war das...
Ich glaube, das war das erste Max Payne,
wo sich die Bullet-Time nicht mal aufgeladen hat.
Können ihr euch daran erinnern?
Ist das vom Mod?
Oder hat sich die Bullet-Time schon immer wieder aufgeladen?
Ah nice, ich habe doppelte Pistols.
Wie ich es nicht gecheckt habe.
Rekt.
Schreckt.
Erreckt.
Wer war das nochmal?
Rekt.
Schreckt.
Erreckt.
Das war doch irgend einer von YouTube, oder?
Was treiben die da?
Das sind Klonsoldaten der Regierung aus einem geheimen Programm.
Story.
Story Mode.
Hättest du mal aufgepasst, Patrick.
Hättest du mal aufgepasst, dann wüsstest du das.
2005, 2005, wir haben vorhin nachgeguckt.
2005 ist es.
Also für 2005 sieht das extrem gut aus.
Wo muss ich nochmal betonen an der Stelle?
Ich muss sagen, die Effekte hier an der Wand, das kann sich auch 2018 sehen lassen.
Die Animationen auch.
Storytelling.
So, irgendwas hier.
Cool Story, Bro.
Weiter.
Ups, ich hätte den Klopf drauf drücken müssen.
Kommt bestimmt Gegner, wenn man Knopfe drückt.
Sollten wir nicht eigentlich schon das Sturmgewehr haben?
Oder?
Sollten wir nicht schon das Sturmgewehr haben, Leute?
Na, anscheinend nicht.
Anscheinend nicht.
Man darf übrigens nur vier Waffen nehmen.
Ähm, was damals gar nicht so Standard war.
Healthpack.
Nice.
Wir haben 100% Leben, easy mode.
Nee, der hat ein Sturmgewehr, da kriegen wir es jetzt her.
Die Grafik ist für die Zeit wirklich gut.
Was ist?
Craiggasm-Grafik.
Mein Problem ist, ich rede mittlerweile in so vielen Twitch-Emotes und sinnlosen Memes,
dass das mir teilweise auf der Arbeit schon rausrutscht.
Das ist dann immer merkwürdig, ja.
Ich meine, stellt euch mal vor, euch steht in der EL jemand gegenüber.
Allein schon, wenn ich jetzt sage EL, ne?
Es steht euch jemand in der EL gegenüber und anstatt dass er was lustig findet, sagt er
LUL.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Alter, raste halt aus, ey.
What the fuck?
Denkst du an Explosives, auf einmal fliegt dir das Bein in die Fresse, ey.
Ich muss mal testen, ob man die Beine abschießen kann, wenn sie schon tot sind.
Das geht wahrscheinlich nicht.
Moment, wir probieren noch mal was.
Granate.
Boah.
Alter.
Ich lade noch mal kurz neu.
Ich nehm mal kurz, ich nehm mal doch diese andere Waffe, weil die hat einen Zoom.
Bein, Bein, Bein, Bein.
Bein ab.
Schnipp, schnapp.
Da gab's doch mal, oh nee, oh Gott, jetzt, nein.
Hör auf, Max.
Mir ist jetzt gerade dieses komische Kinderkrokodili eingefallen.
Kennt ihr das noch?
Das, das war so schlimm.
Damals haben alle gesagt, boah, ist das lustig.
Guck mal, was das...
Ich hab mir damals schon immer gedacht, übelst dummes Zeug, ja.
Alle fanden das, fanden das mega lustig und haben sich dann drüber kaputt gelacht, über
das Krokodil.
Schnieschnaschnap, ja.
Beine ab, Köpfe ab.
Zumindest in dem Game.
Schnibbel ab.
Wir nehmen nicht die Cheatwaffe.
Also nicht die, nicht die Modwaffe, die ist zu OP.
Hat man ja grad gesehen.
Äh, Meinung zum neuen Valve Game Architect.
War das, war das nicht, dass ich jetzt durchlebe, war das nicht das Kartenspiel?
Oder, oder war das dieses Dota, das war das Dota Kartenspiel, oder?
Kommen wir hierher?
Ich glaub, wir kommen hierher.
Übrigens, man kann nicht rennen, das ist, äh, Renn, Renngeschwindigkeit.
Ich muss gucken, dass ich keine Booster verpasse.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, ich mach jetzt, ich mach jetzt nicht das Krokodil an, ganz bestimmt
nicht.
Das Game ist einfach, das ist zu intens, ja.
Das geht nicht.
Ich glaub, hier geht's weiter.
Gab's hier oben noch was?
Oder ging's hier weiter?
Ich bin, ich bin verwirrt.
Ich will nämlich keine Booster Packs verpassen, weil ich kann mich auch dran erinnern, auf
höherem Schwierigkeitsgrad, was wir hier spielen, waren diese Booster Packs...
Hypermonker, ey.
Das ist doch mein Dude, oder?
Der, der aus meinem Squad.
Der sich auflöst.
Bäh.
Okay, ich muss noch mal zurück, ich muss gucken, ich muss Booster Packs holen.
Hier ist nix.
Ah, nice, hier ist einer.
Das ist ein Health Booster Pack, falls ihr's nicht lesen könnt.
Jetzt hab ich ganz nur fünf Lebenspunkte mehr.
Yeah.
Ist das nicht der Bruder?
Nein, das ist nicht der Bruder.
Der Bruder ist...
Nee, wir dürfen nicht spoilern.
Wir dürfen nicht spoilern.
Halt, also Leute hier, no spoiler, please, ja.
Ich hab mich jetzt auch grad verleiten lassen.
Hier geht's weiter in das Story, glaub ich.
Ich will noch mal ganz schnell zu diesem komischen anderen Haus zurück und gucken, ob da noch
ein Booster Pack drinne ist.
Jetzt müssen wir mal kurz abstellen, noch mal.
Und auch wenn ihr das Game kennt, spoilert die Leute mal nicht, denn das Game hat jetzt
zwar nicht die super krasseste ausgefeilte Story, aber die Story ist nicht schlecht.
Und die Story hat am Ende eins, zwei Kniffe, die richtig cool waren.
Und wenn man die gespoilert kriegt, ist dumm.
Nur so angemerkt.
Ach, man kommt hier gar nicht hoch.
Okay, wir rennen wieder zurück.
Jetzt wäre es halt geil, wenn man ein bisschen schneller rennen kann.
Ich mein, man darf nicht vergessen, wir sind da der super krasse Point-Man-Elite-Soldat.
Und der kann halt einfach nicht schneller als so.
Das muss man auch mal verstehen.
Der ist so Elite, hat die besten Reflexe, die geilsten Sachen aller Zeiten, überall.
Aber laufen kann er nicht.
Aber ich mein, es ist auch klar, wenn man in allem der Beste ist, kann man hier auch
noch im Laufen der Beste sein.
Granate, granate, granate, granate. Alter, hol die Granate raus.
Eats.
Was ist eigentlich deine Meinung zu Black Ops 4? Ich find's nicht schlecht.
Also, der Multiplayer ist Bullshit wie immer.
Also der normale Multiplayer ist halt Call of Duty Random Bullshit.
Aber an sich ist es nicht übel.
Mir gefällt's halt.
An den Gesichtern sieht man, dass es von 2005 ist.
Der Kopf sieht irgendwie nicht so passend aus, oder?
Sieht aus wie direkt aus Rainbow Six.
Gab's zu der Zeit überhaupt schon Motion Capturing? Jaja, auf jeden Fall.
Die haben ja sogar schon für Mario 64 sowas wie Motion Capturing.
Also, eine ganz rudimentäre.
Hast du Pixel Doubling? Was?
Was zum Teufel ist Pixel Doubling?
Was macht das?
Game. Nee, Performance.
Advanced Graphics Cards. Effects.
Pixel Doubling. Off.
Half Resolution. Nein, warum soll ich das denn machen?
Hör mal auf.
Warum soll ich das denn machen? Das sieht ja schlechter aus.
Haben wir überhaupt schon mal Damage gekriegt?
Für das volle 2005 Feeling, ja.
Jeden Vorteil müssten wir ja haben, dass wir 2018 haben.
Level Descent von 2005 haben wir schon mal.
Es gibt im Prinzip nur einen Weg.
Taschenlampe.
Oh, ich sag's euch Leute, in späteren Levels Taschenlampe Beste.
Meinung zur Artifakt, ich hab keine.
Ich kann dazu nichts sagen.
Ich musste ja sogar überlegen, ob das nicht das Dota-Spiel, das das Dota-Kartenspiel war von Valve.
Von Valve.
Kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Nice. Hört mal.
Habt ihr gesehen, die haben zwei verschiedene Soundquellen.
Die haben eine Soundquelle für das Telefon und eine für den Hörer.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Also ordentliche Details.
Die wahrscheinlich keines auffallen, der das Spiel spielt.
Aber uns ist hier aufgefallen.
Poggers.
Liebe fürs Detail, eindeutig.
Wenn's flackert, ist immer auch schlecht.
Äh, ah.
Ich war grad ein bisschen verwirrt, als ich grade die Taschenlampe angemacht hab.
Das sieht jetzt...
...seits merkwürdig aus.
Ich seh den Chat nicht mehr.
Weil ein komisches Update davor ist.
Oh, da ist ein Booster.
Den holen wir jetzt.
Okay.
Für die vollen E-Marschen.
Wie viel kostet das Spiel?
Das Spielt, glaub, 8 Euro oder so.
Und du kriegst alle Add-ons mit dabei.
Da stellst einer.
Halspack.
Ich glaub, gleich krieg ich die geilste Waffe in einem Game, die es je gegeben hat.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt kommt oder ob es nicht ein bisschen später ist.
Aber es gibt so eine Nagelpistole in dem Game.
Das ist wirklich ohne Scheiß mit der Gravity Gun von Half-Life eines der geilsten Waffen ever.
Kannst die Gegner so quasi gegen die Wand nageln dann.
Die fliegen dann so quasi durch den Gang und...
Ehe sie jetzt dann.
Ehe sie jetzt dann, wenn es soweit ist.
Kann sein, dass es die gleich gibt.
Oh, das war keine...
Max, das war keine gute Idee, mit dem Pistol langzugehen.
Ich sollte mal eine ordentliche Waffe nehmen.
Das kommt sich ja vor wie bei Siege, ey.
Beschreckt.
Pause?
The fuck, wie hab ich das gemacht?
Wozu kann ich das mit jetzt...
Was?
Warum kann ich in einem Singleplayer was sagen?
Hä?
Man weiß es nicht.
Man versteht es nicht.
Macht nichts.
Nageln gegen die Wand.
Gachibass, ja.
So, Schiengan.
Alter, Max, was ist hier los?
Ja, 4-1 ist hier los.
Das einzige wahre 4.
Restlichen Games taugen nichts aus der Serie.
Lass mich durch!
Das ganze Kickaction bringt nichts.
Aber Games von damals, wie gesagt, keine Sandbox, keine Open World.
Im Prinzip gibt es nicht viele Möglichkeiten, wo man lang muss.
Und ich finde auch ein roter Faden in Games ist so eine Sache, die ein bisschen vernachlässigt wird.
Guckt euch Assassin's Creed Odyssey an zum Beispiel.
An sich ein cooles Game.
Und mit Griechenland auch ein Setting, was ich an sich ziemlich nice finde.
Aber muss das denn irgendwie 150 Stunden lang gehen, eine riesen Welt mit rudimentären 0-15-Quests?
Kann ich nicht einfach sagen, ey, richtig gute Main-Story bis hin links und rechts fertig ist.
Nö, gibt es nicht.
Oh nein, oh Leute, ich habe eine Idee.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Jetzt wird geschreckt.
Passt mal auf.
Granate.
Granate kommt jetzt.
Achtung.
Oh, die werden geowned.
Ich weiß, warum das Game indiziert ist.
Was für eine Sauerei.
Ohne Go-
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Der Mod ändert bloß ein bisschen die Blutech.
Das Game ist im Original relativ ähnlich.
Ich meine, das hat bestimmt nicht der Mod eingebaut, dass man, dass man hier Leute durchreißen kann.
Ah, der Mod hat ein bisschen...
Warum ist das Blut eigentlich weg?
Na gut, das ist halt Harald Games aus der damaligen Zeit.
So, die konnten nicht so viel Blut speichern und Zeug an der Wand.
Vielleicht findet hier jemand raus, ob es eine Config-Datei gibt, wo man, wo man die Blut-Details länger anzeigen lässt.
Das wäre nice.
Also falls das jemand weiß, dann würde ich nämlich einstellen, dass er, dass er kein Blut löscht.
Das wäre sehr nice, wenn es sowas gäbe.
Aber das Game ist im Original genauso blutig.
Vielleicht nicht ganz so wie mit dem Mod.
Aber wie gesagt, der Mod hat neue Bluteffekte und ich glaube auch neue, so neue Innereien-Effekte und sowas in der Richtung.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist das so, wie das die Hersteller gemacht haben halt.
Wenn die Sauerei aufwicht, ja der Garbage-Collector.
Die Programmierer unter uns werden das jetzt wahrscheinlich verstanden haben.
Was für ein ultra krasser geiler Joke das war.
Ich sag, wir haben so viel Helz.
Ey, brauchen wir gar nicht alles.
Können wir eigentlich auf Extrem-Difficult gleichstellen.
Eats as fuck, sag ich dazu nur, sag dazu nur das hier und das hier.
Point man, renn mal ein bisschen schneller.
Keine Booster übersehen.
Vielleicht hier hinten.
Hier wird nicht geboostet.
Und hier kommen wir her.
Das heißt, es gibt nur noch einen Weg, Schlauch-Level-FTW.
Ja Knabber, das war halt auch 2005.
Knäherbär, hast du rausgekriegt, wie das geht?
Hab ich was übersehen?
Die Mod?
Was?
Gibt's den einen, gibt's nicht im deutschen Steam.
Ist indiziert in Deutschland.
Aber auf GOG kannst du das kaufen für 8,29 Euro.
GOG eh beste.
Wenn ich könnte, würde ich mir alles nur noch auf GOG kaufen.
Sogar der GOG Client ist besser.
Alien, habt ihr gesehen?
Der Sellout ist real.
Alienware Notebooks.
Also der Sellout ist wirklich...
Der ist am Start in der Sellout.
Wahrscheinlich haben die noch Teile mitgesponsert vom Game oder so.
Hier sind auf jeden Fall Gegner am Start.
Hier ist eine Rüstung, gut zu wissen.
Brauchen wir gerade nicht.
Haben wir alles schon.
Soll das ein Maus sein?
Lull.
Ach, das geht nicht.
Ach, das ist ja doof.
Ich dachte, man kann die Blutdetails hochstellen oder so.
Also, dass es länger angezeigt wird.
Kollege, jetzt könntest du die Tür in die andere Richtung offen machen.
Jetzt stehst du nämlich dahinter.
Okay, das ist so eine typische Sache aus Games von damals.
Tür auf Trigger Gegner.
Okay, dann nicht Tür auf Trigger Gegner, sondern über die Türschwelle laufen Trigger Gegner.
Okay, fast.
Debated.
Oh fuck.
Ich hatte doch recht.
Ich hatte recht.
Ich sagte doch, die Gegner machen Damage.
Die Gegner machen extrem Damage, wenn man nicht aufpasst.
Schreckt, ja.
Haken wir.
Au.
Über Bande.
Da fliegt ein Arm.
Ich sag mal, die Gegner sind übelst clever.
Stopp, es war es.
Nice.
Können wir uns einen Healthpack, wir haben genug mitgenommen.
Nagelpistole.
Nein, doch nicht.
Fuck.
Ich dachte Nagelpistole.
Wo ist die Nagelpistole?
Beste Waffe in allen Games.
Combined.
Es flackert.
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt das Absicht, dass es hier drinnen flackert.
Nee, das ist keine Absicht.
Pass auf.
Wasser.
Wer Half Life gespielt hat, springt ungerne in irgendwelche Pools.
Wir probieren jetzt mal was.
Geht natürlich nicht.
Ich glaube, das war auch eines der ersten Games, die das so cool hingekriegt hat.
Und später wird es noch viel dunkler.
Alter.
Epileptische Anfälle.
Okay, wir müssen hier runter.
Guckt euch mal an hier.
Ich meine, ich weiß, ich lobe das Game jetzt übertrieben, aber das war für die damalige
Zeit auch cool.
So Lichtzeugs hier zwischen den Stäben durch.
Heute denkst du dir so, das lockt ja keinen mehr hinterm Ofen vor, aber damals war das
schon echt cool.
Sehr, sehr nice.
Stellts jetzt.
Wir Nahkampffrauen den jetzt.
Wir sind schreckt.
Noch die Wassereffekte an der Wand, das ist schon cool.
Ich weiß nicht, soll ich da lang oder da lang?
Ich will nämlich gucken.
Okay, hier lädt das Game.
Dann guck ich erstmal in die andere Richtung.
Nicht, dass ich irgendwas verpasse.
Hopp, hier darf man nicht rein.
Blatsch, blatsch, blatsch.
Oder doch?
Ja, wo geht's denn lang?
Was soll das?
Kein Schlauchlevel?
Fuck, es geht doch nicht hier lang.
Es geht hier lang.
Moment, das ist mir viel zu komplex.
Warum ist es kein Schlauchlevel?
Warum gibt's hier mehrere Wege?
Was soll das?
Ich glaub, wir kommen jetzt einfach im gleichen Raum raus, oder?
Achtung Leute, Granate.
Richtig.
Schreckt.
Hauen wir uns nochmal ein Helzpack rein, wir haben genug.
Das Auto saft.
Oder ist abgekackt?
Ja Leute, ich glaub, das Game ist abgekackt.
Oder auch nicht?
Oder doch?
Oder nicht?
Ich glaub, es ist abgekackt.
Was denn jetzt?
Das Game ist im Vordergrund.
Ich kann es nicht beenden.
Nie raus haben wir ein altes Spiel.
Ja, das stimmt.
Hallo.
Please.
Beenden.
Ben, der N.
Okay, was machen wir jetzt?
Was machen wir jetzt, Leute?
Ja, alt entfernen hab ich ja schon gemacht.
Task Manager ist offen, aber ich seh Task Manager nicht.
Was machen wir jetzt?
Ich brauch eure Windows-Hacks.
Ich hab ne Idee, was wir machen.
Machen wir CMD?
CMD?
Machen wir?
Achtung, Achtung.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Jetzt kommt Trick 17.
Kill?
Können wir Kill 4 machen oder so?
Wie killt man was bei Windows?
WinTap neuen Desktop aufmachen.
Das ist ja auch schon ne nice Idee hier.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Task Manager.
Fuck.
WinTap.
Neuen Desktop.
Neuen Desktop 2.
Oh nice, Leute.
Ihr seid die Besten.
Ihr seid so geil.
Fuck.
Der ist ja noch hier auf.
Win.
Okay.
Neuen Desktop.
Zack.
Task Manager.
Yeah.
4.
Bam.
Nice.
Ich, ich liebe solche Windows-Hacks.
Beste.
Ja.
Dass das überhaupt notwendig ist.
Dass überhaupt eine Anwendung im Vordergrund vom Task Manager gehen darf.
Wenn man den aufmacht.
Ich schon wieder.
Das ist halt Windows-Logik.
Okay.
Loaden.
Wieso kann man in alten Games nicht raustappen?
Kann man?
Übrigens, die Verbindung zum 2.
Desktop ist abgekackt.
Ich kann, ich kann.
Ah, jetzt geht's wieder.
Okay.
Not.
Weiter geht's.
By the way, der Task Manager ist nie im Vordergrund.
Sollte er aber sein.
Das Game ist wieder gecrashed.
Was ist hier los?
Windows.
Die Mod.
Nee, das glaube ich nicht.
Das lief jetzt komplett ohne Probleme bis jetzt.
Windows.
Hallo?
4.
Wir machen 4 noch mal aus.
Ah.
Okay.
Wir machen 4 noch mal aus und wir machen, wir machen Gok noch mal aus.
Was?
Windows, was willst du?
Aber Gok auszumachen ist eigentlich bescheuert.
Kann damit eigentlich nichts zu tun haben.
Wir können, ich hab eine Idee.
Wir machen Dings aus.
Ich sag mal, was wir ausmachen.
Wir machen dieses kack Nvidia Overlay aus, was alles kaputt macht.
Was früher so gut funktioniert hat und mittlerweile übelste Kacke ist.
Dieses Shadowplay Overlay.
Ich wette mit, wollen wir wenden?
Das liegt am Shadowplay Overlay.
Browser, ja nee, Browser kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Aber können wir, wir machen alles zu.
Machen alles dicht.
Außer das Meme Tool, das muss anbleiben.
Aber das ist ja auch von mir programmiert.
Live-Instrument.
Das kann ja gar nicht das Problem machen.
Der wollte Autosave und ist gecrashed.
Das kann sein.
Aber ich hab ja auch einen Quick Save geladen.
Kein Autosave.
Moment, das...
Alter, geht weg.
Was?
Fuck mich nicht ab.
Was macht das denn?
So.
Nur aber.
Ah.
Wir loaden mal den Checkpoint.
Das geht jetzt.
Ich sag euch, Shadowplay-Kacke.
Alter.
Da können wir auch das richtige Game laden.
Das crasht jetzt nicht mehr.
Shadowplay.
Fuck, ist wieder gecrashed.
Ha.
Drecksgame.
Alter, was ist denn hier los?
Okay, ich lad den Checkpoint wieder.
Ist ja gut.
Ich lad, ich lad den Checkpoint.
Aus.
Zack.
An.
Kacibas, ja.
Hoffentlich softlockt sich das jetzt nicht wirklich irgendwie öfter.
Okay, Leute, Bless RNG, Bless RNG, dass hier nichts passiert.
Wir gehen jetzt den anderen Weg.
Wir gehen jetzt hier rum.
Alter, wie es splattert.
WTF.
Wir kriegen nachher noch ne Shotgun.
Und auch die Funken sind sehr, sehr nice.
Okay, save, save, save.
Nice, es geht, es geht.
Sehr schön.
Ah.
Haha, guck mal.
Jump ist wieder nicht gemapped.
Und er hat wieder, er hat wieder meine Tastatur auf Indisch umgestellt.
Windows, was machst du denn?
Warum ist meine Tastatur wieder Indisch?
Was war das für ein Mod vorhin?
Ähm, du, du, du meinst den, den Mod, den ich installiert hab hier für das, äh, für
vier?
Äh, ich glaub M, M-Mod oder so hieß das.
Gucken, dass wir keine Boosterpacks übersehen.
Frag mich nicht, warum ich überhaupt die indische Tastaturbelegung da, da überhaupt
drauf habe.
Ich hab die nicht eingestellt.
Windows ist der Meinung, das, äh, brauch ich.
Wahrscheinlich, äh, weil ich indischer Support-Mitarbeiter bin oder so.
Ich will hier hoch.
Komm ich nicht hoch?
Doch, komm mal.
Story, hat doch nicht umgestellt.
Okay, weil auf einmal ist es jetzt Y anstatt Z für Heal.
Ich werd jetzt nicht neu starten oder so, das muss jetzt einfach so funktionieren.
Ach, hier waren wir vorhin, und jetzt funktioniert's auch, ne?
Hier sind wir vorhin, glaub ich, lang und dann wurden wir geschreckt.
Und wo geht's hier lang?
Hier war man nämlich schon.
Das ist der andere Weg, hier sind wir vorhin langgekommen, ne?
Okay, im Prinzip, ja, im Prinzip ist es immer noch Schlauchlevel, aber offenes Schlauchlevel.
Bam, wie Bruce Lee, bam, nee, Bruce Lee ist eher der hier.
Oh, es gibt noch andere Miele-Angriff, guck mal, es gibt den Zappel-Kick, diesen Zappel-Kick,
und dann gibt's hier so den, so den, ich hab keine Sehnen im beiden Kick.
Wie weit bist du mit deinem Black-Mesa-Youtube-Playthrough?
Ich bin durch?
Das war ein paar Jahren schon.
Ups, das war jetzt sehr clever, hier zu schießen, sehr clever, Max, sehr schlau.
Das sieht echt nicht gesund aus, was das Bein da macht.
AD-Spam ist, ist einzig wahre, guck, AD-AD-Spam, wie in jedem Game, so muss das sein.
Ich bin schon, das Black-Mesa-Let's-Play ist lange durch, weiß gar nicht, was ihr erzählt.
Alter, ist ja gut, oh, das Bein, ich muss mich mal heal so an und mich mal kurz hier,
kurz verpissen.
Treppen campen geht immer in jedem Shooter, Treppen campen geht auch gegen NPCs, gegen
alle, Treppen campen ist das Beste.
Guck, das mein ich, die Gegner sind richtig clever, der hat jetzt gewartet, bis ich hier
hoch gelaufen bin, nur um mich von hinten zu awnen.
Poggers KI, hast du Poggers KI?
Ach, der hängt da oben rum.
Oh, oh, was ist das?
Ich hab grad, Moment, ich hab grad noch einen anderen Kick gemacht, habt ihrs grad gesehen?
Habt ihr grad gesehen, das war eher so ein Drop-Kick oder sowas eben noch, ich hab den
dann gemacht.
Oder war das einfach nur ein Bug, was weiß ich, das ist ja nicht der Plus-Di-Simulator.
Oder haben wir hier irgendwie noch einen Booster-Pack?
Wo ist der Schatten von der Mauer, genau, ach hier, ach passt, der Schatten stimmt
sogar.
Nee, hier ist sonst nix.
Siehst du deinen Charakter, ja man hat Füße, guck mal, man hat Füße, voll modern.
Oh, man hat sogar eine komische Sprung-Animation, für 2005 ist das schon, sehr, sehr nice.
Guckt euch mal die Animation von dem Typ an.
Wunder mich zwar, dass es hier gar keine Packs gibt, aber gut, keine Packs gibt, kann man
nix machen.
Ich brauch die Nagelpistole, unbedingt Nagelpistole, au, die machen übelsten, alter die machen
übelsten Damage, ah Booster, nice, mehr Bullet-Time, kann man immer gebrauchen, voll
Multi-Schatten, für die damalige Zeit auf jeden Fall, Physik-Engine-Test, nee, funktioniert
nicht, ich denk mal hier gehts weiter, kommt man hier oben drauf, hier oben drauf, sieht
nicht so aus, irgendwo ne Leiter gesehen, ah, hier, okay das heißt man muss hier irgendwie
durch.
Das alte Wolfenstein, du meinst das, nee New Order war das letzte oder, nee New Order
war das, das davor meinst du, ne, das der Reboot quasi, ja das ist nice, hab ich noch
nicht gespielt, ich hab nur das ganz neue gespielt, ja, das wollte ich auch nochmal
spielen, aber unbedingt vorher müssen wir noch ne Runde Soldier auf Fortune 2 spielen,
auch mit Mod, jetzt guck mal, meint ihr man kann hier rüberspringen mit Special, mit,
es geht bestimmt, fuck, meint ihr das geht, da kann man bestimmt übelst klitschen, Klitsch
aus, nice, oh fuck, nee da braucht man Speedrun Strats, das kann ich nicht, geiles Speedrun
Strats, Helps, Grenades, Weste, Gewehr, aufs Rohr, geht nicht, nicht vorgesehen, drehen,
ich find das immer cool, das alte, vor allem alte Shooter haben immer irgendwelche Turbinen
Rätsel oder Schalter Rätsel oder, ja, irgendwie so Drehding Rätsel, weil, ich hab keine Ahnung,
weil, weil das so ist, was haben die Games damals halt gerne gemacht, Sekunde, oh, ich
komm nicht rüber auf den anderen Desktop, ich kann jetzt keine rare Parode anmachen,
save, Gegner, alter, warum machen die so Damage, ja, du magst alright sein, deine Kollegen nicht,
das ist echt geil, die Schachtgarn nehmen wir mit anstatt der OP Waffe, Shotgun ist das
beste in dem Game, neben der Nagelpistole, ist das echt geiles Teil, ist hier irgendwas,
da war es, da war es, da war es, ich hab schon ein bisschen Schiss vor den späteren Levels,
da stellt man viel zu sehr mit der Taschenlampe in dunklen Ecken rum, am Anfang geht es noch
ein bisschen, aber die späteren Levels sind echt so der Schocker in dem Game, ok, darum,
darum, gehen wir mal hier rum gucken, ok, hier gehts anscheinend weiter, gehen wir erstmal
hier rum gucken, ist nix, MonkaS, das meinte mit Shotgun beste in dem Game, M, M, M, M,
M, und das sieht auch ohne Gormor zu aus, vielleicht nicht ganz so über das, nicht
zu übertrieben
hier habe ich irgendwie booster packs
übersehen health pack health pack komm ja sag oh minen sehr nice aha story
okay aus lull ich hänge fest ist da oben was
sind wir hier noch mal hochgekommen wir sind hier so hochgeklettert da oben ist
noch ein health pack und das brauchen wir das game ist nicht so einfach vor allem die spätere
level sind nicht ohne kannst du mal die alten splinter cell teile ich muss euch ehrlich sagen
ich habe splinter cell nikos gespielt aus dem zweiten teil und den auch nicht viel ich habe
von spielter cell überhaupt kein schimmer könnte ich aber machen können wir eigentlich
spielen weil ich ebenso der höchste splitter cell loop bin der hat mich gereckt hallo
es geht jetzt ab granate
das ist die nagelpistole beste was
leute was was werfen wir weg die doppel pistols oder die smg weil wir haben wir haben ja im
prinzip dass wir haben das assault rifle die shotgun eigentlich ist egal was wollen wir
wegwerfen ich überlasse euch das mal schott smg oder pistole
pistach pistel pistach smg ja das ist jetzt ist gleichstand smg doppel pistols leute ihr
macht mich fertig das ist das ist ja 1550 die ganze zeit pistole ok ok pistole pistole
wir machen die pistole weg jetzt haben wir den nagelwerfer das ist also ich weiß nicht
ob man das hier zeigen kann aber es ist die geilste waffe in dem ganzen game der nagelwerfer
also übrigens waffe weggeworfen nicht weggeworfen die dinger gibt es laufenden im level neu
also ist nichts dabei
schreckt
voll in der hasch
da war ein booster schon booster gesehen da hinten war noch was ne jawoll doppel booster
reno x 22 gibts das zeug überhaupt noch kenntst du jemand mit aus mittlerweile sind doch wahrscheinlich
bei x 25 oder so von hinten genagelt das war ja aber wieder klar dass so was kommt
er macht es auch so viel damage das nagell nagell nagell wo ist er weggenagelt es blutet
wir heben uns den nagelwerfer auf das für schwierigere falls ding ist übelst op
hitze effekt also wie gesagt wer mal jemand half life gespielt hat egal ob eins oder zwei
man springt eigentlich ungern in sowas hier rein eigentlich macht man doch was gar nicht
freiwillig aber man muss man muss
anspecken ich hab gedacht wer wieder gequetscht
jetzt lasst euch mal nicht von den feministen erwischen dann ist vorbei dann ist das schluss
mit lustig alles der spaß wirklich vorbei kann man kann man nicht aber kann er oben
irgendwie lang hier gehts weiter gehen wir hier noch einmal außen rum gucken
jetzt weiß ich wie man jetzt weiß ich wie man wie man slidet das ist ja übelst das
geht ja überhaupt nicht man muss ach du scheiße habt ihr also man slidet man leidet in dem
man springen was ist denn das rennen springen mehle und dunklen gleichzeitig wer macht denn
sowas rennen springen mehle und dunklen nee also ernsthaft das benutze ich nicht das ist
mir zu das ist mir zu abgedreht das kriegst ja kriegst ja hier entzündung in den fingern
wenn du das machen willst es ist es ist eben nicht springen und dunklen das dachte ich
am anfang es ist es ist springen mehle und dunklen gleichzeitig also ich drücke gerade
jetzt müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen ich drücke gerade cv und lehrtaste plus nein ich drücke
w cv lehrtaste gleichzeitig dass ich slide wer hat sich das ausgedacht da geht ja der
finger kaputt bei der nagler wird aufgefüllt hier waren wir schon hier waren wir doch war
man hier schon ja den haben wir schon genagelt den typ hier ok was gewappen was genau möchte
das gelb von uns das werden wir zu machen wir müssen hier rüber oder wir müssen bestimmt
hier rüber ach wir müssen schalter rätselchen schreibt nach makro ja kann ich mal die komische
korsale makrosoftware verwenden die für sonst nichts kannst du mal rausklettern die für
sonst nichts gutes korsale korsale was genau macht hier eigentlich die hitze
zombis hat an wie kotz zombis
Ich weiß nicht, was du darüber sprichst.
Einige Geheimnisse werden besser und tiefer als andere.
Aber ich weiß, wo ich hin muss.
Nein, warte! Du hast den falschen Typen!
Hör auf jetzt, Mr. Moody.
Es ist Zeit, um zu reden.
Bitte, nein!
Ach, das Game hat eine Batterie in der Flashlight.
Das ist mir noch nie aufgefallen.
Oh, nein!
Es ist in der Flashlight. Es wird auch nie aufgefallen.
Sags euch chat wenn euch die feministen erwischen dann ist vorbei
Dann kriegt ihr auch klor in schritt gesprüht wie in der russischen u-bahn habt ihr das video gesehen
Das ist total das war total hängen geblieben
Da ist irgendeine russische feministin durch die u-bahn gelaufen hat irgendso irgendeine klor sonst was mischung den männer in schritt gesprüht
Alter jetzt ist ja mal gut
Ey das war doch fake war das echt fake ich hoffe das war fake das video das war
Richtig schwonker erst gerade war das fake also ich meine ich fände es gut wenn das fake war weil das war schon so unglaublich übertrieben und
Männer verachten quasi dass ich mir gedacht habe ey jetzt kann es ja nicht sein also wenn das fake war ist gut
Das ist halt was das haben sie nur in 4.1 hingekriegt dass du dass du permanent denkst es ist was obwohl überhaupt nichts ist
Und sei es so dass du an einem hammer hängen bleibst das braucht halt wirklich sehr feingetuntes level des sein sodass du quasi hier hängen bleibst und so schon cool gemacht
Nix da
Gehen hier
Ein booster und grenades und shotguns perfekt
Komischen hier dran rechts rum rechts rum okay gucken wir mal rechts rum da entweder darum da vorher gab es doch nichts oder
Ne vorher vorher gab es nix es muss hier rechts lang sein
Ich sehe gerade dass mich jemand gehorstet hat danke für den Horst
Ich sehe leider nicht wie viele Leute gekommen sind
Weil ich das so auf dem anderen monitor habe
Nochmal fall ich da nicht rauf rein mein halbes Magazin zu verballern
Ein Typ gehorst nice
Wahrscheinlich dich selber
Na klar bleibt da
Ich habe das eigentlich ausgeschaltet mit dem dass nur ein
Ich habe irgendwie eigentlich ich habe bilden wir eigentlich habe eingestellt hosting nur ab 10 oder so
Was sind mich jetzt der halbe chat
Was gibt es
Ich mache hier nicht sauber
August fast
Wo geht's denn jetzt weiter
Hier kommen doch hier oder ich bin verwirrt
Die Dose
Wo geht's weiter
Noch mal sehr erfolgreich habe ich mir auch schon aufgeschrieben
Wir spielen noch mal
Nix da
Im Wasser in welchem Wasser
Jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen
Es ist falsch rum
Was geht
Ich
Gute das Games von damals immer so auf Lüftungsschächte gestanden haben
Half Life 1 besteht ja das halbe Game aus Lüftungsschacht
Wir stellen uns jetzt hier an
Ich habe gerade durch Kopf geschossen
Da
Nein! Fuck! Ich dachte, sie sind alle tot.
Hinnagelt!
Zum Glück haben wir die ganzen Helzpacks aufgesammelt.
Kommt man hier rauf? Achso, übrigens Leute, also wir spielen das Game auf jeden Fall durch,
ne? Ich sag's euch noch mal. Vielleicht nicht unbedingt alles heute, die Kampagne ging ja,
glaub ich, irgendwie sieben, acht Stunden, aber auf jeden Fall morgen. Wobei,
ne, so lang ging die Kampagne nicht. Ist ja gut, weißt du, ich schieß hier mit dem Nagel
in den Kopf und was passiert? Der ganze Typ fliegt auseinander. Ja, die Shotgun raus, ja.
Ich glaub, hier können wir die Shotgun nicht verwenden. Hinnagelt! Shotgun!
Nein, nein, Max nicht nachladen! Schreckt!
Ich wollte es mal probieren, ich wollte es mal probieren.
Haben wir hier irgendeinen Boosterpack oder so vergessen? Ne, ne, hier ist kann nichts sein.
Hi. Skate? Geht's in die Richtung oder geht's in die andere Richtung?
Keep out, natürlich. Ich kann nicht weiterspielen, sorry, ich kann das Game nicht durchspielen,
oder? Ich muss outkeepen. Ich komm im gleichen Raum jetzt raus, oder? Ist nicht der gleiche
Raum? Doch. Lull. Aber nicht der gleiche Raum wie da oben, oder doch? Remote Bombs! Sehr,
sehr nice. Remote Bombs. Leute, ich speichere mal kurz, geh da hinten in die Ecke, guck
ob da was Gutes drin ist und wenn da nichts Gutes drin ist, lad ich wieder. Das Spiel
hat dich zu sehr geschockt als du 12 warst, mach dir mal nichts drauf. Mich hat es beim
ersten Mal durchspielen auch übertrieben geschockt. Zu wenig Schlauchlevel. Zu wenig
Schlauchlevel. Hier ist ja, hier ist ja noch Zeug. Na, langsam machst du nichts. Wow,
ich sag euch mal Leute, die Gegner sind cleverer. Guck mal auch, wie die sich zurückziehen
und so. Die Gegner sind cleverer als in den meisten Games heute. Voll geflankt und ich
werde mit euch, der ist nicht hinter mir gespawnt, der ist wirklich, weil er mich gehört hat
von hinten geflankt. Der Niedler. Ja, komm. Äh, übelst rumgeschrien und jetzt nichts
da. Na toll. Auf jeden Fall der beste Teil der Serie, jaja. Also für mich ist 4-1 der
einzige Teil der Serie eigentlich, weil die anderen total sucken. 4-1 ist, man könnte
schon fast sagen Meisterwerk. 4-2 ist gewollt und nicht mehr gekonnt, warum auch immer.
Und 4-3 hab ich nicht gespielt. Wahrscheinlich ist 4-3 richtig schlecht. 4-3 hab ich mir den
Trailer damals angeguckt und hab mich schon gedacht, ist das euer Ernst? Ein Koop-Game,
also ein, ein 4 Action Koop-Game, das hat mit 4 überhaupt nichts mehr zu tun. Auch vom
Ernstteil her und so alles überhaupt nicht mehr nach 4 ausgesehen. Leute, ich blick
nicht mal durch, so viele Räume und alle Räume sehen gleich aus. Okay, okay, wir sind
hier. Wir sind hier, wir gehen jetzt wieder hier hoch, in den komischen Lüftungsschacht.
Da ging's bestimmt weiter. 4-3 ist mega trash, ja, ja, wirklich, geh ich mal ganz stark
voll aus, glaub ich dir, glaub ich dir. Der Trailer sah schon so trashig, so übelst kacke
aus. Sie haben es ja geschafft im dritten Teil, quasi, dass man, dass man quasi den
Held hier und, und, und den Bösewicht hier aus dem ersten Teil irgendwie im Koop spielt
und so. Hä? Weil es überhaupt keinen Sinn gibt, auch in der ganzen Story nicht. Basiert
4 auf der Quake- oder Source-Engine, weder noch, ist was eigenes. Ich mein, wenn es Source
wäre, würden die Gesichter besser aussehen und die Physik wäre anders. Das wäre auf
jeden Fall schon mal ziemlich offensichtlich gewesen. Quake würde für die damalige Zeit
noch eine ganze Ecke, eckiger aussehen. Hier waren wir doch schon. Wie sind wir jetzt
doch umsonst hier lang gelaufen? Sind wir umsonst hier lang gelaufen? Hätten wir auch
gleich durchlaufen können. Mega lul. Okay Leute, ich hab ein Problem, wo geht's lang?
Hier? Nee. Wo geht's lang? Ah! Es hat Auto-Safe, das heißt, hier geht's lang. Shotgun. Shotgun-Baschen.
Hä? Rekt! Sprudelt noch. Was ist das denn für ein
Schuss? Brauchen wir noch ne Rüstung? Brauchen wir noch ne Rüstung. Needle haben wir
herausgepasst mit Range. Oder auch nicht. Okay, dann geht's wahrscheinlich hier lang.
Na, hier auf die Range können wir auf jeden Fall wieder den Shotgun nehmen. Es hat schon
eine Ähnlichkeit mit Half-Life 2. Ich glaube, das kommt einfach daher, weil's zu einer ähnlichen
Zeit rausgekommen ist. Wann kommt der nächste Science and Technology Stream? Mal gucken,
wer wir das hier durchhaben. Hä?
Vorsicht. Wisst ihr was? Wenn da Scott gewesen wäre, wäre man jetzt so um die Ecke gegangen.
So? Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung? Wäre es Rainbow Six gewesen, wäre man so um die
Ecke gegangen? Wäre es CS gewesen, wäre es CS gewesen, wären wir wahrscheinlich so um
die Ecke gegangen. Hat jedes Game irgendwie so Science. Cool Story Pro Max. Ihr wolltet
es schon sagen, oder? Gibts zu. Oh ho. Ein Midi-Pack. Moin heiliger Bim Bam. Brauchen
wir noch ne Rüstung? Rüstung please. Achso, Battle Royale wäre noch anders da gewesen.
Battle Royale wäre jetzt so gewesen, hier drauf, Wingsuit auf, runtergeflogen und dann
haben Spawnix gehabt und gestorben. Story. Nee, kein Story. Man kann ja fast die Schrift
lesen. Sehr, sehr nice. Äh. Ich wollte ja irgendwann zu den Luftsprengen, das finde
ich nicht gut. Das ist nicht approved von mir, Sachen in die Luft zu sprengen. Checkpoint,
da ist passiert was. Schleicheck. Oh. Nein. Nagel behalten. Granaten will ich haben. Moment.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob man die Dinger jetzt kaputt schießen darf. Das war
glaube ich keine so gute Idee, oder? Oder sprengen die mich in die Luft, wenn ich in
die Nähe gehe. Jop, machen sie. Load. Also muss ich im Endeffekt eh hier durch. Gears
of War. Gears of War. Ohne Scheiß Leute, Gears of War spiele ich nur, wenn ich das
mit dem Farmer zusammenspielen kann. Gears of War, das erste wohlgemerkt, nur das erste.
Die anderen waren auch wieder trash, irgendwie. Oh. Wo sieht man eigentlich, wie viele Medipacks
man hat? Acht. Also wenn Fabian Coop Onstream würde ich das durchspielen. Das erste Gears
of War. Der hat eine Xbox One. Das Ding ist Backwards Compatibility Approved. Ein Ghost.
Neue Gegnertypen. Poggers. Ich fand nur den ersten Gears Teil gut. Und das lag daran,
weil sie sich dort nicht ernst genommen haben. Was, also sie haben so auf Bedeutungsvoll gemacht,
war es aber letztendlich nicht. Es war dann so Fuck yeah, bam in your face. So halt wie
Gears of War ist. Und ab Gears of War 2 haben sie angefangen aus diesem quasi in your face,
wir sind die geilsten und sehen Leute durch. So also eine emotionale Story zu machen, was
bei Gears of War überhaupt nicht passt. Die gibt ihnen etwa scheiße. Oh shit. Outaimed.
Da rum, da rum oder da rum? Hier kommen wir her, oder? Kommen wir hier her? Ich kann mir
diese Level nicht merken. Was auch immer. Die Level sind teilweise ziemlich verwirrend.
Also hier waren wir auf jeden Fall noch nicht. Und da ist auch ein Booster. Das heißt wahrscheinlich
geht es hier auch nicht weiter. Weil dort wo Booster sind ist immer Abseits von der
Main Quest. Dementsprechend geht es hier auch nicht weiter. Muss man nicht gucken. Wo geht
es denn hier unten weiter? Ist ein Loch. Ach, die sind immer am Anfang rausgekommen. Spielst
du eigentlich am PC immer noch in Full HD oder was sonst? Alles andere hat ja keinen
Mehrwert irgendwie. 4K ist bei Filmen ganz nice und selbst da ist es eigentlich nahezu
überflüssig, wenn man ein bisschen weiter wegkommt. Und wenn man sich überlegt, was
für eine riesen Performance ein Booster 4... Hallo? Krasser Elite Soldat, spring hoch.
Okay, will nicht. Spring mal runter. Gibt ja nun ein 4K 144 FPS Monitor. Jaja, für 1500
Euro oder so. Ich habe mir schon überlegt, ob ich ASUS mal nerven soll, ob man da nicht
irgendwas machen kann. Aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, also ich bin prinzipiell mit
1080p zufrieden. Früher habe ich immer so ein bisschen geguckt zu Zeiten von 1024x768,
1024x768. Habe ich immer geguckt und dachte immer so, ja, ein bisschen höhere Auflösung,
hier ein bisschen, da ein bisschen. Aber seitdem es 144Hz mit Full HD gibt, bin ich wahrscheinlich
in Sellout Mode, bin ich wahrscheinlich an meine visuellen Grenzen gestoßen, das ich
gar nicht mehr brauche. Ja, okay, auf einem größeren Bildschirm vielleicht, aber auf
einem größeren Bildschirm sitzt man auch meistens wieder weg. Wenn man von einem 32
mm Bildschirm natürlich direkt davor sitzt, okay, dann lasse ich mir das gefallen. Aber
ich brauche das in meinem Setup nicht. Und ich sage damit nicht, ich will es nicht, sondern
ich brauche es einfach nicht. Wo geht es hier lang? Booster, nice. Neue Waffe, sehe ich
das richtig? Ja gut, dann behalten wir die Waffen so. Dann halt keine Submaschinen ran.
Was haben wir hier? Zack, zack, Nades. Damn, next. Die braucht es nicht, doch, doch, die
braucht es. Ja, heute hätten wir übrigens überall ein Quest-File, das hat jemand im
Chat gerade geschrieben, das stimmt auch. Oh, schreckt den Kopf. AD-Spam, dem seid
ihr nicht gewachsen, Leute. AD-Spam, da könnt ihr den mithalten. Das ist Overwatch-approved,
das CSGO-approved, das Battlefield und Cotton-approved mein AD-Spam. Da können auch die mind-controlleden
Elite-Klonsoldaten hier nichts gegen mich machen. Übrigens, die Story, falls ihr das
vorher nicht verstanden habt, wo die Gegner herkommen, oder falls ihr noch nicht da wart,
das ist ja eines der Games, die versucht zu erklären, warum es 3 Millionen Gegner gibt
und warum die einen bashen. Der Typ, den man dazwischen durch zu sieht, der mind-controlled
die, also sprich, das klingt total bescheuert, wenn man das erklärt, aber so ist das lauter
Story. Also, das sind Klonsoldaten, das ist ein geheimes Programm der Regierung und der
Typ, den wir eigentlich killen sollen, der ist so psychisch, so telekinese-mäßig, wie
nennt man das, so mind-control-psionisch, fragt mich, wie ist das richtige Wort für,
der kann die kontrollieren und deswegen hat er jetzt quasi alle geheimen Klonsoldaten
der Regierung uns entgegen geworfen und will uns bashen. Ja, das meinen die ernst, also
ist das in der Story. Achtung, wie hast du das überlebt? Oh, was ist das hier? Munition
ist leer. Alter, was soll das? Ich dachte, ich kann euch jetzt geil hardscopen von hier
oben, aber das geht nicht. Gibt es hier noch was? Oh, eine Ustung, Soldreifel-Munition,
noch mehr Granaten. Wir haben Granaten voll, wie es aussieht. Cool Story, Max, ja ich
weiß. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Achtung, die schießen wir jetzt ab beim Runterlaufen. Ha, Lul. Geiler
Versuch, Kollege. Oh, fuck. MonkaS. Komm her, wo bist du? Oh, oh, oh. Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, zersplattert. Gegner, sind hier noch Gegner überhaupt? Die Musik ist voll am Start, aber
ich glaube, ich habe die outplayed, weil ich den Heli gebashed habe. Ich glaube, die wurden
absolut outplayed gerade. Die Musik denkt, hier sind noch 80 Gegner, aber es ist kein
einziger mehr da, weil ich den Heli gebashed habe. Nice. Alter, was hältst du aus? Ja,
drei Dinger im Kopf, ist klar. Das sieht aber echt unangenehm aus, muss ich jetzt mal sagen
hier. Das sieht echt unangenehm aus, der Typ. Okay, Shotgun ist auf die
Range nicht gut. Komm, wir nehmen mal unser neues Assault Rifle. Das hat kaum Munition,
das ist scheiße. Wir nehmen mal das normale Assault Rifle, da haben wir noch so viel Muni.
Wo sind sie? Wo sind sie? Kleine Stellzeilenz, wo sind sie?
Oh, der hat es gesplattert. Alter, wie kommt der Dude hinter mich? Kann mir das mal einer
erklären? Spawn, Spawn-Cheat? Wie ist der hinter mich gekommen, der Kerl? Das war Spawn-Hack.
Hast du dir das Spiel bei Steam gekauft? Nein, das habe ich mir bei Gok geholt. Gok,
das ist der beste. Grenade. Au. Nein. Fuck. Ah, ja. Nochmal der ganze Scheiße. Okay, guck
mal Leute, der Dude ist gerade hinter mir gespawned. Da, da kann mir doch keiner erzählen,
dass der auf einmal da war. Payback-Spawn-System, so sieht es aus, ja. So wirkt es echt. Wir
machen es jetzt anders, wir machen jetzt Trick 17. Wir legen jetzt hier so eine Mine hin.
Wie detonaten die von selbst, wenn die Leute dran gehen? So, und nun machen wir mal kurz
nach und hauen ab. Okay, jetzt habe ich mir anders vorgestellt. Was jetzt, wo sind denn
die Gegner? Aha, und jetzt werden sie gebasht, Shotgun. Pass auf. Komm her. Okay, ich bin
hier. Die Gegner sind nicht doof, ne. In jedem anderen Shooter werden die mir voll hinterher
gerannt. Ich sag euch, die Gegner in dem Game sind echt klapper. Alter. Warum machen die
Gegner so viel Damage? Okay, dann machen wir das wieder wie am Anfang. Slow-Mode in your
face. Granate. Weckt. Okay, ich bin hier. Okay, ich bin hier. Okay, ich bin hier. Okay,
jetzt kommt der Juggernaut gleich noch. Okay, ich bin hier. Okay, ich bin hier. Okay, jetzt
Wow, alles eingesammelt, weiter geht's.
Chuggernauts könnte ein bisschen mehr droppen.
Armour, Needler, Armour, aber wir haben genug Helzpacks, das passt.
Muss man sich keine Gedanken machen.
Pissisch, Alde.
Kann man wieder nicht durch.
Ich geh wieder rein, zack, Granate, Soldier Rifle.
Noch ne Runde Pick trinken, oh ne.
Das sind Gegners.
Gegners.
Also wir können jetzt hier lang oder durch die Tür.
Needler, bam, volle Polle.
Oh Scheiße, wir kommen immer rein.
Oh, da kommen noch mehr.
Hallo?
Soldier Rifle?
Wo ist er?
Schreckt.
Alter, die wollten es aber wissen.
Ist da noch einer?
AD Spam, da kannst du nichts machen.
AD Spam OP, keine Chance.
Noch ein Jungle, was ist mit denen los ey?
Mehr Gegner ey.
Kopf, Kopf, Kopf, Kopf, Kopf, so viel kannst du gar nicht aushalten.
Was soll denn das?
Shotgun.
Was, was, willst du mich verhalten, was macht der für Damage?
Was machen die denn für Damage?
RIP, richtig RIP.
AD Spam, keine Chance.
Unsere Health Packs sind bald weg.
Shotgun.
Ach, war es das?
Eben war doch hier noch ein anderer Typ.
Okay, einsammeln.
Gucken, ob es hier noch irgendwelche Booster oder so zu looten gibt.
Oh, ich werde abgeholt.
Nice.
Hier darf man nicht.
Wie?
Einfach fertig?
Ja gut, dann gibt es hier auch keine Booster-Items mehr.
Wenn man keine Levelnamen sich ausdenken will, sagt man einfach Intervall 4.
Aufstehst auch am Fenster.
Zack, hat es einer überlebt?
Nope.
Oh, an das Level kann ich mich erinnern.
Das ging mir beim ersten Tourspiel richtig auf den Keks.
Da gibt es gleich Stells-Gegner, um euch mal vorzuwarnen.
Stellsen richtig rum.
NA-Aim.
Alter, dafür habe ich jetzt nicht verdient.
Mach mich blatt, Alter.
NA-Aim.
Guck mal, der Typ steht rum, bewegt sich nicht.
Und was mache ich?
Ich schieße vorbei.
Die Gegner haben gerade ein bisschen KI-Aussetzer, so wie es aussieht.
Zack.
Oh nein, nein, nein, Shotgun.
Okay, hier geht es noch nicht rein.
Ich muss erst mal aussen um Keycard sammeln, was auch in Spielen aus dieser Zeit sehr beliebt war.
Keycard sammeln, Duke Nukem und Quake 2.
Ich meine ja so, die Keycard sammelt Games schlechter.
Du musstest ja verwenden, Scheiße, ich will die Keycard sammeln.
Da gab es natürlich Keycards.
Da gab es dann noch in Gelb, in Blau, in Grün, in Rot.
Und dann musstest du ja mal gucken, welche Keycard bringt dich wohin im Level.
Also, es war nicht alles gut in Games früher.
Also, manche Sachen gingen aber auch wirklich auf den Keks.
Keycard sammeln in Leveln, die alle gleich aussehen.
Das war auf jeden Fall früher was, was mich genervt hat.
Oh, nix da.
Direkt splattered.
Da machst du nichts.
Da gehst du down.
Also Leute, wenn ihr irgendwie den Fabian überredet bekommt,
mit mir Gears of War zu spielen, auf der Xbox One.
Das heißt, ihr müsst zu ihm in den Stream, weil er dann irgendwann mal online ist.
Wenn ihr ihn überredet kriegt, spiele ich auch Gears of War.
Aber alleine habe ich keinen Bock.
Wir fahren ja zusammen, Koop würde ich das machen.
Einer ist doch noch da.
Wo ist der Typ hin?
Ich bin schon dran mit Fabian.
Ist der live, ist der on der Fabian?
Was war denn das jetzt?
Warum hat es den nicht umgebracht?
Moment, sorry Leute, muss ich noch mal reloaden.
Oh, hier ist ganz schön viele, ganz schön viele Gegner.
Sag mal, machen die so einen Damage?
Ey, guckst du dir das mal an?
What the fuck?
Die haben mich gerade instant gone, die Typen.
Instant weggeklatscht.
Bam, bam, bam hat es gemacht.
Zum Glück habe ich genug Ammo, genug Rüstung, genug Leben.
Genug Health Packs.
Schreckt.
Next, your face.
Oh ja, looten.
Mehr zu looten gibt es nicht.
Der war fast auf kein Video.
Okay.
Da kommt was.
Pre-naded.
Bam.
Best, so muss es sein.
Weiter gehts.
Looten, looten, da hinten ist noch ein Mini-Pack gewesen.
Aufheben.
Zack, Spritze.
Oh, und das Level hat Stellens Gegner.
Ich habe auch keinen Bock drauf.
Next.
Shotgun ist das geilste in dem, mit Shotgun und Nagelpistole.
Sehr, sehr nice.
Ich wollte die Shotgun nicht ablegen.
Wir könnten eigentlich die SMG mitnehmen.
Solange wir keine Muni haben für das Assault-Reife.
Neues Health Pack, nice.
Wir können uns gleich noch eins gönnen.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Adi, adi, spam, adi, adi, spam.
So nicht, Kollege.
Was denn jetzt?
Mele?
Was geht jetzt ab?
Warum habe ich jetzt Nachkampfangriff?
Wie wählt man den aus?
Boah, schreckt, Alter.
Voll in die Fresse.
Warum habe ich jetzt Nachkampfangriff gehabt?
Effektive Reichweite für eine Shotgun.
Eine Shotgun ist hier eine Scheißwaffe für.
Das ist keine gute Idee.
Okay, machen wir mal ordentlich.
Zack, next.
Übrigens, mir fällt gerade auf, das sind abgecradete Gegner.
Die machen mehr Damage.
Zack.
Oh, ich erinnere mich noch.
Das sind gleich ganz furchtbar nervige Stellensgegner.
Das machen alle Spezialeinheiten so.
Das gehört zum Standard-Training einer Spezialeinheit.
Vor allem, man beachte, die nicht vorhandene Animation zwischen Beinen anziehen und Beine oben.
So, jetzt bin ich pumped, jetzt geht es los.
Das geht nur, weil ich gesprungen bin vorher.
Ups, ich habe das Licht ausgekickt.
Das war sehr clever, Max.
Sehr clever, Licht auszukicken.
Ganz furchtbar schlau.
So, okay, ich muss tatsächlich das Licht auskicken.
Übrigens, vergesst, wir spielen das heute noch durch.
Best Game.
Weiß ich, ob alte Spiele besser waren?
Oder aus mir einfach nur so vorkommt, weil ich die schon gespielt habe?
Aber machen die Games von damals einfach mehr Bock?
Komisch, oder?
Was war das?
Na klar.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Medizine, Telefon, Dr. Pepper, abgeschlossene Tür.
Morgen dann 4-2, nein 4-2, fand ich nicht gut.
Morgen spielen wir Soldier of Fortune 2 oder sowas.
Um die Splatter-Sache.
Okay.
Stellt Gegner, ich habe es euch eingekündigt.
Wenn wir Soldier of Fortune 2 spielen, dann um die Splatter-Sache fortzusetzen hier.
M, Chuck Norris Style.
Nice und dense Game, sup.
Den Derp.
What the fuck?
Nope.
Sehr laut.
Remote-Bomb.
Durch den Baller-Teil vom Game sind wir ziemlich durch.
Ach, hier kann ich nicht durch, das ist zu hartes Material, oder was?
Durch die Tür darf ich das schon mal, nice.
Storytime.
Wir gucken erstmal, wo das Viech da drüben hingelaufen ist.
Ich bräuchte mal ein Panzer, also eine Rüstung bräuchte ich mal.
Das wäre nicht schlecht.
Ah.
Ich weiß noch, das war dem Level hat ich übelst Schiss, als ich das das erste Mal gespielt habe.
Wegen sowas hier.
Wonka Giga.
Da ist noch was.
Gut, dass es Bullet-Time gibt.
Hier waren wir schon.
Kann man hier raus?
Nope, das geht natürlich nicht.
Das sieht nur so aus.
In your face.
So dunkel.
Outcome, nice.
Okay, wo geht es lang?
Hier geht es lang.
Erst mal krach machen, dass jeder weiß, dass ich jetzt um die Ecke komme.
Okay.
Okay Leute, wo geht es lang?
Wo geht es lang?
Hier liegt bestimmt irgendwo jetzt eine Karte, die ich aufnehmen muss, die ich bloß noch nicht gesehen habe.
Hier ist die Kaffe, da waren wir gerade drin.
Ich sehe es, wo es lang geht.
Kopp, Kopp.
Echt?
Fest genagelt würde ich sagen.
Shotgun wieder raus, Shotgun ist hier die beste Sache drinne.
Da muss man schon mal durch sein.
Also nicht durch das Game, durch das Level.
Das geht.
Okay.
Zum Glück ist das Game nicht mehr gecrashed.
Wir machen quasi jetzt eine Sammel-5-Äpfel-Quest für den Typ sozusagen.
Chips? Eine nice Chips-Tüte. Mit einem nice Anrufbeantworter.
Geh ich nass? Na klar.
Wir stürmen das jetzt. Wir gehen jetzt voll ab.
Alter, machen die einen Damage auf dem Schwierigkeitsgrad? Das ist ja nicht normal.
Alter, was? Fuck, ich habe 130 Leben und 35 Rüstung.
Alter, was ist das denn?
Was denn? Damage? Das ist doch nicht normal.
Na gut, dann brauche ich wenigstens mal meine ganzen Items hier.
Ich habe sowas auch.
Schreckt.
Ich habe genug Leben. Ich brauche bloß noch mal eine Rüstung.
Was geht hier? Nix.
Ich glaube, das ist der Flank-Weg, den ich eigentlich hätte gehen können, wenn ich sie einfacher killen will.
Flanken in 2k18, wer will denn sowas schon? Flanken ist komplett overrated.
Frontal in your face ist das Mittel der Wahl.
Ammo, give Ammo, give Mine, give Milchpistole, give Schalter.
Oh, das kann ich nicht killen.
Ok, ich habe die Quest erledigt, wie es aussieht.
Rebooten kann ich.
Da habe ich beruflich langjährige Erfahrungen mit Sachen Rebooten.
Nicht eine Sache kann und das ist Sachen Rebooten.
Und man glaubt gar nicht mal, wie viele Sachen das funktioniert mit den Rebooten.
Funktioniert sogar bei meinem Kühlschrank, wenn er brummt. Rebooten geht wieder.
Achtung, nee.
Laufen wir alle schön in die Shotgun, das ist nice, habe ich keine Probleme mit.
Weiter geht's.
Shotgun, ich will Shotgun Ammo.
Give eine Physikola Blitz, beste Textur im ganzen Game, wie es aussieht.
Also wenn man sich in dem Game für eine Sache fürchten muss, dann ist es die Physikola Textur.
Hier tropft irgendwas.
Da oben liegt auch was drin.
Hier waren wir schon, oder?
Nee, das sieht einfach nur so gleich aus.
Aber noch gar nicht.
Aber hier tropft es überall aus der Decke.
Kommt man da hoch?
Nee, sieht nicht so aus.
Ich blicke nicht mehr durch.
Wo ist hier was?
Hier ist der Sauberraum.
Natürlich, wer kennt das nicht, der Sauberraum mit panzersicherem Glas.
Und ein großes Schild, Activate.
Nice, wir brauchen jetzt die Remote Bomben.
Brauchen die Bomben?
Wie wirft man die?
So, so, Achtung Anfall.
Bam!
Was?
Die Bombe sackt aber.
Was ich interessant fand, eben ging das Glas noch nicht kaputt.
Aber jetzt geht das Glas kaputt.
Und einzig um allein, um mich zu erschrecken.
Checkpoint, sind wir richtig?
Schön um die Ecke jumpshotten.
So, dass man das in kort gelernt hat.
Entweder, entweder, entweder slidet man, wo man ja vier Tasten für drücken muss.
Jumpshot.
Jetzt dreht er wieder durch.
Ich habe den Schock im Moment nicht mitgekriegt, da oben war er, glaube ich.
Ich habe nicht hingeguckt.
Heutzutage wäre das anders gelaufen, Leute, sage ich euch.
Dann hättest du es gemacht.
Und dann wäre die Kamera automatisch dahin und hätte rangezoomt, dass du siehst, oh, da passiert was.
Weil guckt euch mal die Katzins in kort an.
Immer, wenn irgendwie eine Katzin ist und du bist eigentlich gerade hier am gucken oder machen, macht es dann.
Dass du es auch schön siehst.
Ich meine, man steckt ja nicht so viel Geld in Katzins und gedönst rein, um dass die Leute sich da nicht sehen.
Das ist ja schon bescheuert.
Geht es euch einfach mit dem Sack, dass ich so viel speichere?
Ich habe so einen Tick bei allen Singleplayer-Spielen, wo man Autospeichern kann.
Zu speichern.
Wo?
War klar, dass Katzins kommt.
Wow, eine Katzins, in der mir was passieren kann.
So haben wir aber nicht gewertet.
Katzins sind per Definition so, dass einem nichts passieren kann.
Und auch nicht mal Quicktime-Events.
Das überfordert mein Gaming-Hirn aus 2K18.
Was ich toll finde.
Was ich toll finde, was Games teilweise machen, ist, wenn quasi so Anspannung simuliert wird.
Da machen sie in Games immer...
Atmen die dann übelst ins Ohr.
Mein Extrem-Nord.
Eww.
Es liegen keine Brüste rum, hatte das gerade gesagt.
Achso, das heißt, ich soll mich verpissen.
Hab ich schon verstanden, Game, hab verstanden.
Das sieht nicht gesund aus, ja das stimmt.
Ah, Level vorbei.
Zack.
Nice, nice, nice.
Ich guck noch mal kurz, ob es da weiter geht.
Bevor wir das in Lüftungsschacht stellten.
Fuck, hier geht es wirklich weiter.
Nein!
Was hab ich denn da hingeworfen?
Mate!
Oh, den hat es zerrissen, den hat es zerrissen.
Jawoll!
Woll die Granate rein.
Ich find's halt geil.
Sie wollen mich flanken.
Flanken ist ja eigentlich, dass ich dich mitkriege und was sagen sie?
Flank him.
Ah, das ist ja nicht so, was ich das denn mit hören würde oder so.
Ins Knie.
Skyrim-Style.
Also Leute, wenn ihr einen flanken wollt, schreit immer Flank him.
Flank him.
Achtung, ich flanke.
Zack!
Weiter geht's.
Shotgun raus.
Haben wir hier noch irgendwas?
Ein Boosterpack oder so?
Story.
Streamst du eigentlich öfters, ja?
Ja, relativ oft.
Du kannst ja mal in die Historie gucken.
Kommt schon öfters mal vor.
Gibt's hier irgendwas?
Nope.
Noch mehr Story.
Story.
Loa.
Alter, Loa.
Achtung, die hat's gebashed.
Die können ja auch humpeln.
Das ist mir noch gar nicht aufgefallen bisher.
Bisher wurden die immer komplett geschreckt.
Ja, gleich.
Ich hol dich gleich raus.
Erstmal gucken, ob alles kaputt ist.
Probier mal was aus, kurz, Leute.
Lul.
Gebated.
Passiert überhaupt nichts.
Fake.
Fake News.
Postfaktisch.
Das Ding echt blutiert nicht.
Muss ich den Typ jetzt da hinschieben zum Ausgang oder was?
Nee.
Muss ich nicht.
Zum Glück.
Bashen, alle Bashen.
Zack.
Bam.
In your face.
ASMR Stream.
Beste Spiel für ASMR Stream.
Kann man sich bestimmt richtig gut bei dem Spiel entspannen.
Fällt mir nichts besseres ein.
Entspannungs-Game als das.
Moment, lauf ich grad im Kreis, kann das sein?
Wisst ihr, was bei einem aktuellen Game passieren würde?
Da wird entweder daschen, drücke M, um dir die Map anzusehen, wo du hin musst.
Oder es würde in der Mitte, hier oben, so hier oben, ein Pfeil kommen und dir zeigen,
wo es langgeht.
Moment.
Oh, ich noob, ich bin, ich bin mit zurückgelaufen.
Lul.
Wie schlecht.
Aber das sieht auch alles gleich aus, oder Leute?
Sagt man.
Das sieht doch alles gleich aus hier.
Ok, Fahrstuhl.
Wir sind beim Fahrstuhl.
Da ist er doch.
Nein, ist er nicht.
Juggernaut.
In den Arsch.
Nice, erwischt.
Wow.
Das sind meine Dudes, oder?
Das sind meine Dudes.
Aber die sehen genauso aus wie die Gegner.
Als ernsthaft, hätten die erkannt, dass das jetzt nicht Gegner sind?
Die sehen doch genauso aus.
Na?
Was geht?
Wo sind wir durch?
Und wo soll ich, ach ach, ich soll die zu dem Typ zurückeskortieren.
Verstehe.
Machen wir.
Wenn ich den Typ noch finde.
Hier.
Ne.
Ey, dieses, diese Bürokomplexe, du kannst dir doch hier nichts merken, wo es lang geht.
Hier.
Ja.
Ne.
Wie komme ich her?
Oh, Bürokomplex.
Please.
Na?
Ich, ich würde auch nicht barrieren.
Machen wir.
Wir machen ja alles.
Wir machen Fetch-Quests.
Überhaupt kein Ding.
Moins, Fox Development.
Oh, es leckt.
Story.
Wollt der andere Typ nicht mitkommen?
Wo hat er mich gebaitet?
Was, safe?
Ihr kommt garantiert.
Kommt garantiert was.
Das ist aber auch nicht gut für Leute mit epileptischen Anfällen.
Oh ja.
Story?
Wer Story?
Aha.
Na, wie praktisch.
Wie praktisch, dass der Fahrstuhl grad da ist.
Es war so klar, dass der Fahrstuhl, oh, kommt doch an.
Ich muss mir gleich mal was zu trinken holen, was Neues.
Wir sitzen natürlich tight.
Warum sollten wir auch nicht tight setzen?
Wo geht's eigentlich lang?
Hier komm ich her, ne?
Äh, Moment.
Da ist zu.
Oder geht's anert auf?
Aufs Dach.
Ha?
Anert.
Ich muss bestimmt hier hoch irgendwo.
Was sag ich doch?
Jetzt wieder Lüftungsschächte einkloppen.
Weil das in Games von dieser Zeit halt so ist.
Half Life 1 war das Schlimmste, was Lüftungsschächte einkloppen angeht.
In Half Life 1 hast du echt die Hälfte der Zeit Lüftungsschächte eingekloppt.
Eigentlich müssten wir mal das originale Half Life 1...
Das originale Half Life 1 spielen.
Was passiert denn eigentlich, wenn ich da Granate reinwerfe?
Nicht viel.
Was passiert denn, wenn ich da rein springe?
Instant Death.
Weil's auch so hoch ist.
Und ich gepolstere also.
Alienware Sellout Time.
Cool Story Bro.
What?
Gibt bestimmt keinen anderen Weg von da nach da als hier über das Ding draußen.
Wäre nicht möglich gewesen.
Jetzt werden sie gesniped mit einem Needler.
Headglitch.
Sag's euch Leute, Headglitch.
Headglitch of Doom.
Aber die KI in dem Spiel ist so gut, du weißt wirklich...
Guck, die sind clever.
Die sind auch f***** nachladen müssen.
Die sind clever.
Der kommt nicht einfach hier vorne um die Ecke, wo ich ihn schon mal gesehen hab oder so.
Aber eine sehr, sehr nice KI ist das hier in dem Game.
What?
Warum überlebt ihr das?
WTF?
Warum?
Also der erste geht down bei einem Needler im Kopf, ne?
Guck, der erste ist down.
Der explodiert sogar.
Den nächsten interessiert der Needler im Kopf nicht mehr.
Lass los.
Schreckt.
In your face.
So.
Weiter geht's.
Also ich meine, ich versteh schon, warum das Game indiziert ist in Deutschland, ne?
Zum Glück ist Twitch keine deutsche Plattform, sondern hätte ich echt ein Problem.
Einer lebt auf jeden Fall noch.
Jetzt nicht mehr.
Drei Stunden vor meinem JavaScript-Stream.
Krass.
Nice.
Wobei, das war ja so ein...
Ich habe keine Ahnung von dem, was ich mache.
JavaScript zusammengebastelt.
Oh, zusammengebastelt-Stream.
Aber wenn es dir gefallen hat, ist es...
Sehr, sehr nice.
Splatter.
Weggeniedelt.
Shotgun.
Zack, Tür zu.
Alles schön zersplattert.
Es wäre geil, wenn es noch einen Mod gäbe, dass das Splatter-Zeug länger da bleibt,
weil das ist ja nach zehn Sekunden immer weg.
Jetzt haben wir schon die besten Splatter-Effekte, die es für das Game gibt.
Jetzt bleiben die Dinge aber nicht da.
Wir sliden noch mal.
Leute, ich hab noch kein Game erlebt, wo sliden so unglaublich schwer ist wie in dem.
Du musst wirklich W, C, W, Space zusammentrücken.
Alter, wer hat das ausgedacht?
Next.
Die haben mich jetzt natürlich gehört.
Es war ganz clever, dass ich da rumgeballert habe.
Salt-Rifle, komm mal her.
Weiter geht's.
Warum können die um die Ecke schießen und ich nicht?
Find ich unfair.
Wo ist meine Immersion?
Und ich hoffe, das war's.
Damage.
War ein gut Damage, die Dude.
Safe.
Shotgun raus.
Shotgun ist die beste, oder?
Achtung.
Bam.
Oh, die hat's zerrissen.
Noch mehr, Achtung.
Noch mehr.
Next.
Bam, noch mal zerrissen.
Und noch mal zerrissen.
Jawoll.
Warum machst du nichts mehr mit Samra?
Ich hab mit ihm noch nie wirklich was gemacht.
Wir haben einmal Gameplay geshared.
Ich hab einmal was von ihm zum Wurm gezeigt.
Und einmal hat er von mir ein Freefall gezeigt.
Das war alles.
Ich gucke ab und zu noch bei ihm.
Ich weiß ja, ob er noch bei mir guckt ab und zu.
Aber, ähm, gibt's ja nichts mehr bei mir.
Lull.
Debated.
Aber wir haben wirklich was gemacht.
Wir haben ja nie miteinander.
Was auch schwierig ist.
Ich mein, ich kann zwar technisch Englisch labern.
Ja, mich verständigen.
Aber es ist schon nicht so easy.
Außerdem ist die Zeitzone komplett anders.
Oh, RIP Hammer.
Moment, ich wollte...
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich will das Booster Pack.
Nee, nee, nee.
Wie komm ich an das Booster Pack hier oben?
Hier oben war irgendwo ein Booster Pack.
Ich hab irgendwo ein Booster Pack gesehen.
Wo war denn das?
Da.
Wie komm ich dahin?
Ah, Treppe hoch.
Übrigens, das ist Renngeschwindigkeit von einem Elite-Soldat hier gerade, wie man sieht.
Der hat's halt drauf.
Ah, Booster.
Nice.
Ein nicer Booster.
Jetzt können wir hier hochklettern und die Story-Mission weiter machen.
Das Game schockt ein Laufen mit irgendwelchen komischen Geräuschen voller Seid.
Alter, was soll das hier?
Denkst du immer wunderbar, was es... äh, darf ich hier drüber?
Oh, das ist ja ein Schlepple.
Warum machen die Gegner so krass viel Damage?
Alter, was ist das hier?
Guck dir das mal an, wie die mich weglatschen.
Okay, das musst du mit Bullet-Time machen.
Und zwar ordentlich mit Bullet-Time.
Also erst mal schön weggeniedeln, die ersten paar.
Die ersten paar werden weggeniedelt.
Ah, fuck.
Kack, Nate.
Schreckt.
Und jetzt holen wir die Shotgun raus.
Und odens weg.
Und dann wieder in Deckung.
Ah, so geht das.
Wisst ihr?
Und nicht ein Leben verloren.
Von hinten.
Oh.
Weggefleckt hier.
Äh, what?
Passt.
Ähm, das ist von 2011 oder so, das ist...
Also bei mir findest du das Video, das Gameplay von ihm, musste irgendwie so irgendwie der größte Camper aller Zeiten, das ist.
Und bei ihm hieß das, hieß das...
Irgendwas wie Flawless Freefall.
Oh nein, ist eine AUG.
Eine AUG, die brauch ich.
AUG.
Steyr AUG.
Ich hab gehört, Leute, falls ihr CSGO spielt, müssen wir mal sagen, ob das stimmt,
dass in CS jetzt die SG und die AUG,
die wurden jetzt gebufft.
Und jetzt gibt's die ersten Leute, die meinen, dass jetzt sich das Meta shiftet,
so dass manche Leute in CS tatsächlich SG und AUG spielen.
Ist da was dran?
Sagt ihr dazu.
Schreckt.
Wie's auseinander splattern.
Brauchen wir hier... Ah, Rüstung, sehr schön, sehr schön Rüstung.
Sehr, sehr nice Rüstung.
So nice Rüstung.
Danke für die ganzen Follows übrigens heute wieder.
Ich wär noch irgendwie zum krassen Let's Player, ich sag's euch, Leute.
Ich war ja früher so,
so voll Anti-Let's, fand alle Let's Plays doof, immer.
Einzigen Let's Plays, die ich guck, ist Dance Gaming, das Dance Gaming ist das Beste.
Das Witzige ist, dass Dance Gaming fast zu Hause wie ich, oder ich fast wie Dance Gaming.
Nicht abhauen, die Leute.
Oh, fuck.
Warum schießt die Polizei auf mich?
Polizei nicht auf mich schießen.
Sind wir in GTA, oder was?
Ich muss nochmal neu laden, ich hab nicht gedacht, dass jetzt hier auf einmal...
Dann willst du eigentlich Twitch-Partner werden, weiß nicht, keine Ahnung.
Ich hab mir da jetzt noch keine tiefgreifenden Gedanken zugemacht.
Also, ich sag ja immer, ich kümmere mich mal drum, aber ihr wisst ja, wie das ist.
Bis jetzt ist da noch nichts passiert.
Oh.
Arm fest getackert.
Da hängt er.
Guckt euch an, Leute.
Einer müsste noch da sein.
Der hängt auch.
Alle schön fest getackert.
Ich hab immer so viel Munition.
Immer so viel Munition.
Fuck.
Schmeckt.
Ok, wo geht's jetzt lang, unten oder oben?
Tagt sich schon ein Gegner.
Die halten ja mehr aus, wie die anderen Typen.
Und jetzt, Alter, warum sind da so viele?
Oh.
Noob.
A nade noob.
Sag mal, ist der jetzt gespawnt vor mir oder was?
Lol.
Rekt.
Massive wrecked.
Ich glaub, das war's.
Jetzt sind wir wieder oben.
Super.
Helzpack.
Nee, wir sind woanders, ne?
Nee, wir sind gar nicht da, wo wir angefangen haben.
Bam.
So habt ihr euch das net gedacht, ne?
Tür zu, wie in Battlefield.
Oh, Tür geht nicht zu, weil die Tür blockiert.
Tür geht immer noch nicht zu.
Ja, ich lad grad nicht mehr so viel hoch, weil's keine Games gibt, die mir gefallen.
Also, die sich für YouTube eignen.
Und sowas hier ist ja let's play technisch viel besser aufgehoben auf Twitch.
Oh, die hat's zerrissen.
Oh.
Monkeys.
Das war gedacht, als ich da runterfalle, okay.
Ich hab Hunger.
Was ist?
Ist schon 18 auf 15.
Wann haben wir angefangen?
Mach mal einer bitte up time.
Boom.
Big shock.
Du plus du is form minus one to three quick maths.
Big shock ist auch dead meme.
Dabei punch.
Das schockt mich net so, ey.
Was soll das denn?
Das Game willst du jetzt grad wissen?
Ist das das übliche, äh, Gebäude bricht ein?
Taktik?
Hau mal nimmer.
Äh, ich würd mal sagen, nope.
What the fuck?
Spam.
Me weed, me spam.
Mortbucker, if ban.
Warum gibt's eigentlich für jeden Scheiß irgendeinen dummen Spruch?
Könnt ihr mir das mal erklären?
Warum gibt's nicht für irgendetwas einfach mal keine dummen Sprüche?
Vor allem auf Twitch.
Ähm.
Hier kann man nicht durch.
No shit.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Ich meine, hier irgendwie.
Gerade durch Jumpsworn oder so?
Au.
Pass mal auf, ich slide da jetzt durch.
Durch Slide...
O, nein, das geht nicht.
einen nicht deutschen Tastatur-Lehauts kommen jetzt vielleicht.
Kann das sein, dass man hier nicht mehr raus darf? Doch.
Falls ich überhaupt richtig lang laufe, schauen wir mal.
Nop, geht's nicht lang, oder?
Nee, war schon richtig.
Hier komm ich ja her, ne?
In dem Game sieht vieles schon ziemlich gleich aus.
So.
Okay, wir müssten wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Ventile wieder zudrehen.
Weil es ein Game ist von 2005, da hat man das so gemacht.
Da hat man Ventile zugedreht für Schalterrätselchen und sowas.
Oder vielleicht hat man auch sowas hier abgeschossen oder so.
Ach da, da muss man, da muss man was machen, ne?
Drauf schieben. Nein, auch nicht.
Oh!
On fire.
Ist er.
Hm.
Sag mal.
Muss ich den jetzt machen?
Hier auch runter.
Jawoll.
Oh, die Reaps sind los im Chat.
MonkaS.
MonkaX.
War das? Da reicht MonkaS nicht mal.
MonkaX. Guck mal, ob ich MonkaX enabled hab, Leute.
MonkaX. Groß X.
Ah, ist enabled. Nice.
Nice, Max wenigstens mal das richtig gemacht.
Das Level sieht so gleich aus.
Hier bin ich doch gerade lang, oder?
Ich bin lang und dann rechts hoch und die Treppe hoch.
Genau, und ich hab Ventil inventiert.
Richtig.
Wie enable ich das gar nicht? Du gibst einfach MonkaX ein.
Ach so, du siehst es nicht? Weil wir sehen es.
Du musst in deine Better Twitch TV oder in deine Franker Faces Settings gehen und sagen, dass du animierte Gifts haben.
Was ist? Was ist? Game! Was ist? Oh!
Wisst ihr was das Schlimme ist? Es ist jetzt 18.20 Uhr und es wird dunkel hier.
Also es wird dunkel hier gerade im Büro.
Was für das Game nicht förderlich ist.
Tut, nice.
Krasse Jump Skills. Komm jetzt, krasse Jump Skills.
Hallo. Ich bin stuck!
Doch nicht stuck.
Fast stuck.
Better Twitch TV sendet zu viele Sachen an den Entwickler und die
an den Entwickler und Browser Verlauf. Was denn zum Beispiel?
Also ich meine, so gegen App Nutzungsdaten habe ich jetzt keine Schmerzen.
Aber gut, dass du mir sagst, ich werde es mal auf dem zweiten Browser einfach deaktivieren.
Moment Leute, Better Twitch TV deaktivieren.
Franker Faces Z ist eh die bessere, das bessere Addon.
Ich habe es nur noch hier auf dem alten Browser installiert.
Jetzt mal Manage Extensions und Extensions off.
Was sendet es denn oder ist das nur Panikmacherei?
Ich meine, hier komme ich her.
Hier war ich doch eben gerade.
Vielleicht muss man hier runter, muss man bestimmt...
Die üblichen Ventilquests.
Browser Verlauf.
Sender das wirklich meinen Browser Verlauf an den Hersteller?
Graphic Glitch, Exposed.
Das wäre scheiße, wenn es das wirklich macht.
Alles ist ja gut, Kiste.
Weil dein Browser Verlauf braucht...
Nein, mein Browser Verlauf braucht der Better Twitch TV Hersteller nur wirklich nicht.
App Statistiken lasse ich mir immer gefallen.
Oder Addon Statistiken, das ist anonymisiert, das ist ja vollkommen in Ordnung.
Du willst dir irgendwie auch wissen, was mit deiner App gemacht wird.
Und wie und zum verbessern.
Ok, es ist grün.
Es leuchtet grün, was tut es?
Wartet mal kurz, Leute.
Oh, ich bin weg.
Ok, es ist grün.
Aber das ist ganz schön kacke, dass das meinen Browser Verlauf sendet.
Das muss nicht sein.
Was sagt denn der Hersteller dazu?
Der wird ja da bestimmt nicht einfach nichts zu sagen.
Moin, Ivan.
Der Hersteller, der hat sich doch bestimmt dazu geäußert.
Letztendlich ist er ja auch sehr Community abhängig mit diesem Browser Plugin.
Da war man grad.
Ich bin verwirrt.
Game, wo muss ich hin?
Bam!
Schreckt, bam, noch mehr schreckt.
Wartet mal, Granate wechseln ist das hier.
Boom.
Splatter.
Granate wechseln.
Nice.
Oh, oh, oh, noch ein Charger da unten am Start.
Jetzt ist er down. Perfekt.
Und das kaum Leben zu verlieren.
Was es bei mir gibt, bei mir gibt es gleich wahrscheinlich einfach Brötchen mit entweder Mozzarella oder Salami oder irgendwie, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Hab ich eigentlich das Zeug aufgezammelt von dem?
Habe ich nicht.
Salt Rifle Munition, Salt Rifle Munition.
Musik.
Zack.
Leute, ich muss jetzt mal während dem, während dem Fahrstuhl, ich muss mal kurz hier Futter Futter mal holen.
Bin gleich wieder da.
Musik.
ETF.
Warum spawnen, damit ich direkt hinter Gegner, wenn ich AFK bin?
Was soll denn das?
Achtung.
Stellts H.
Und sagt man immer und ist komplett outdated.
Aber es hat auch keiner mehr schreckt und recht ist auch nicht recht recht geht eigentlich noch recht recht ist immer noch angesagt rechtes.
Kommt das eigentlich her?
Bei dem, bei dem meisten Blödsinn, der so im Inhalt geschwätzt wird, weiß ich, wo das herkommt direkt her.
Wer regt da wen?
Einzige, was mir bei FrankerFaces Chat und bei der Twitch TV seit dem Twitch Update noch fehlt, ist eine History vom Chat.
Kennt da jemand ein gutes Addon zufällig für?
Also sprich, dass wenn ich im Twitch Chat was schreibe und dann nach oben drücke, dass ich quasi eine History habe von dem, was ich geschrieben habe und die gleichen Sachen nochmal schreiben kann.
Das konnte bei der Twitch TV früher, seit dem vor dem Twitch Updates.
Vor dem Twitch Update.
Ich kann gar nicht das Deutsch mal reden heute.
Was ist das halt?
Zu viel Fear.
Wo ist eigentlich Kokona hin?
Kokona war mal kurz eben da und wir haben einen Server für ihn Rebooted und jetzt ist er weg.
Da ist Kokona.
Der Shitstorm war ja schon wieder mal groß, weil Siri von der Schwarzen gespielt werden soll oder der Asiatin.
Ich glaube, das haben sie offen gelassen.
Der Shitstorm ging ja mal wieder ab.
Die Leute haben echt teilweise schon Probleme.
Ich meine, ich kann in dem Fall sogar beide Seiten irgendwo verstehen.
Man muss ja nicht aus allem irgendwie so ein Racism-Thema machen.
Viele Leute, die Witcher mögen, sei es aus den Spielen oder aus den Büchern, für die ist Siri einfach weiß mit weißen Haaren.
Das heißt, die Idee da jetzt unbedingt jemand Schwarzes hinzusetzen.
Aber solange Siri weiße Haare hat, das ist glaube ich das Wichtigste an der ganzen Sache.
Aber auf der anderen Seite kann man sich auch über ungelegte Eier schon ganz schön aufregen.
Was soll ich eigentlich machen? Wieder Server Rebooten oder sowas?
Poggers, ja echt Poggers.
Solche Türen haben die gerne in Spielen.
Habt ihr in eurem Leben schon mal irgendwo solche Türen gesehen?
Hier fällt nämlich nichts ein, wo ich jemals solche Türen gesehen hab.
Die hat's hoffentlich zerrissen.
Au!
Oh, was eine Sauerei.
Oh, noch mehr Splatter.
Übrigens, die sind im Original auch ohne Gormor ziemlich explodiert bei der Shotgun.
Was? Granaten oder so?
Nehmen wir mal Niedler.
Ernsthaft? Meinst du das ernst, Patrick, oder ist das Jebait?
Ich hab sowas noch nie in echt gesehen.
Jaja, das macht Sinn. Unbestreitbar macht das Sinn.
Im Labor, wo man durch Türen gehen muss und Sachen in der Hand hat, dass die Türen automatisch aufgehen.
Das auf jeden Fall, da sag ich gar nichts gegen. Ich hab sowas bloß noch nicht gesehen.
Das hört sich an wie ein Plastikflash, oder?
Da ist wahrscheinlich der Sound-Creator gefreut bei...
Hier ist nix.
Ich weiß immer nicht, ob Niedler oder Shotgun. Das ist alles so mid-range zu close-range.
Weggesniped.
Shotgun. Wenn sogar das Game mit dem Shotgun in die Hand rückt, da sag ich mal nein.
Hier liegt doch bestimmt irgendwo noch... Nein? Nicht? Kein Booster?
Vielleicht vorne im Gang noch ein Booster. Booster?
Hier Booster. Come on, brah.
Ne. Gibt keinen Booster mehr.
Sauerei.
Na gut, dann ich.
Zack. Hüpf.
Hüpf.
Okay. Kein Bock.
Die Musik.
Nein, nein. Er versucht nicht zu flanken. Er versteckt sich. Ballert euch in den Fuß.
Oder ins Knie besser.
Nix mehr da.
Mann. Midi-Pack reindrücken. Ah, schöne Rüstung. Nice.
Kann man das anziehen? Nein. Das ist ein Kopf. Das kann man wahrscheinlich eher nicht anziehen.
Moin, Reflow.
Du piss dich, Alter.
Wie wollen die jetzt zu mir kommen?
Wie wollen die zu mir kommen? Gar nicht, oder?
Kopf. Lidler. Kopf.
Au. Okay Leute, ich glaube, das müssen wir anders machen.
Umkreis.
Das erinnert euch nur wegen der Shotgun an Half-Life, oder? Kämpft zu.
Achtung. Schneiber. Schneiber.
Schneibt.
Der ist noch hinter der Seil, oder?
Seht ihr das? Der wartet sogar, bis ich nachlade. Die Gegner sind mega clever in dem Game.
Weiß gar nicht, warum die sich in neueren Games so schwer tun.
Oder vielleicht, vielleicht ist einfach nur...
Na ja, was heißt, die neueren Games tun die sich schwer? Ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass es auch schwieriger ist, wenn du eine ordentliche Open World hast und sowas in der Richtung, was ja zurzeit verlang gesagt ist,
eine ordentliche Gegner-KI zu machen. Ich meine...
Guckt euch mal die Gegner-KI in Assassin's Creed an.
Das ist für mich das beste Beispiel von gewollt, irgendwo auch gekonnt,
aber nicht in diesem Umfang, wie man das gebraucht hätte.
Die Gegner in Assassin's Creed sind gar nicht immer so blöd an sich,
aber ich mein, guck mal, wir stellen das mal nach.
Also, Assassin's Creed, da wird es jetzt so laufen, wenn es hier ein Gegner ist,
den haue ich an, schaffe nicht zu töten, renne weg, renne weg, renne weg,
renne in den Busch hier und der Gegner stellt sich dann vor mich...
Wo ist der hin?
Hm, Assassino, Assassino.
Hm, er ist wohl weg.
Okay, ich laufe jetzt einfach wieder meine normale Route weiter.
So, und stelle mich wieder an der gleichen Stelle hin, wo er mich vorher assassin hat,
dass er mich nochmal assassin kann.
Das ist so die Assassin's Creed-KI.
Zweite Assassin's Creed-KI, was wir auch nicht auf die Reihe kriegen, ist...
Ich schieße Gegner an, kletter irgendwo drauf
und der Gegner klettert mir ewig lahm nach,
anstatt irgendwas zu verwenden mit Range.
Nein, das machen wir nicht, wir rennen lieber hinterher.
WKF.
Alter, halt verrecken hier.
Muss ja auch der letzte Bob was reißen können.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das in Assassin's Creed so viel damit zu tun hat.
Ich glaube, die tun sich einfach nur schwer,
dass man in Assassin's Creed so eine Bewegungsfreiheit hat,
plus eine KI, die nicht unfair sein soll, indem sie alles hittet, so nach dem Motto.
Man könnte ja auch sagen, so war es ja realistisch.
Also sprich, wenn in einem Dorf irgendwie der krasse Attentäter rumrennt,
wie in Assassin's Creed, und dann die Wände hochkratzelt,
da klettert man nicht hinterher, sondern nimmt eine Range-Waffe
und ballert den Typen weg.
So würde das jeder machen, denn die Typen haben Speere dabei,
die haben Bögen und sonst was.
Also wenn du nicht total bescheuert bist,
aber das ist halt Assassin's Creed, da klettern sie hinterher.
Und ich bin ja auch immer begeistert,
wie viele Leute in Assassin's Creed klettern können.
Weißt du, auf der einen Seite ist Storytechnisch,
da sind halt die Assassin, die obergeilen Free-Runner und Stealth-Typen halt.
Und dann, in der normalen Mission, kann sie jeder.
Das ist halt Assassin's Creed Logik.
Wo ist hier überhaupt irgendwas?
Moment, ist das da, wo ich gestartet bin?
Ernsthaft?
Was muss ich denn überhaupt machen?
Wofür gibt es Schwierigkeitsgrade?
Tja, der Assassin's Creed Odyssey ist Schwierigkeitsgrade auch schwer.
Sind die wirklich schwerer in dem Sinn?
Die Gegner halten einfach nur mehr aus,
und die Gegner halten einfach nur mehr aus,
sind die wirklich schwerer in dem Sinn, die Gegner halten einfach nur mehr aus,
also sprich, du musst den gleichen Scheiß einfach nur fünfmal machen anstatt einmal,
was es jetzt halt nicht schwieriger macht und auch nicht besser vom hohen Schwierigkeitsgrade.
An sich finde ich, das ist ein cooles Game.
Da muss ich lang, das sieht alle so gleich aus hier.
Hier muss ich durch, ja?
Hier muss ich bestimmt durch.
Assasino.
Haben sie in Assassin's Creed 2 doch immer erzählt?
Du bist durch die Straße gerannt, hast alles umgerannt, ja?
Und außer Assasino ist ihnen nichts eingefallen.
Und wo muss ich denn hin?
The fuck?
Okay Leute, ich hab' Activated, ja?
Hier war ich doch schon, ich hab' schon die Typen geownt.
Was muss ich denn machen?
Da ist er!
Kokona.
Ähhh...ähh...
Hier war ich schon, ich hab' die Typen geownt.
Ich hab' die Typen geownt.
Ja
Hier war ich doch schon, oder? Ich muss jetzt durch den komischen Schacht durchlaufen.
Ne in Assassin's Creed zum Beispiel werden die Bots nicht schlauer. Ich glaube es ist auch ziemlich
schwierig eine KI zu programmieren für Gegner die Schwierigkeitsgrad abhängig Dinger macht oder
sein lässt. Weil da musst du ja auch sau viel reinstecken ja und wenn du jetzt was cooles
programmiert hast das Gegner flenken können dann willst du das natürlich auch überall verwenden.
Und wahrscheinlich sind die Gegner einfach scheiße wenn sie auf einmal ihre Flanktechnik
nicht mal verwenden können. Ich muss mal kurz das Brötchen beißen.
Social Eating Stream
So ich glaube jetzt sind wir gleich aus dieser komischen Forschungsstation oder was das hier
ist aus diesem Labor raus. Fiss dich alter.
Oh die halten mir ein bisschen viel aus die Dinger.
Reload. Safe Hack. Aha ich weiß schon was passiert.
Rekt. Oh es lebt.
Okay so viel als kann ich aus.
Kampagne KI Beste. Ja genau. Ich dachte hier geht es jetzt weiter.
Muss ich ernsthaft wieder zurück. Ich glaube ich gar nicht dass ich wieder zurück muss.
Oder ich muss nicht zurück. Doch ich muss zurück. Tatsächlich vor allem wisst ihr was
ich mal echt muss. Ich muss mal echt aufs Klo.
Was ist los. Was kann man gegen diese Dinger machen.
Okay einfach abschießen. Das ist ja einfach.
Bist du bereit da zu flühen.
Ah
Oh
Kann man das vielleicht umlaufen das Ding?
Wär ja auch ne Möglichkeit
Ich finde mich nicht
Zu Recht hier Leute
Aha, wow
Du ist da
Hier komme ich her, ne?
Hier komme ich her, komme ich hier her?
Ich glaube schon, ich glaube hier komme ich her
Hier komme ich her
Ja, da komme ich her
Das
Ich hätte das Ding also deaktivieren können
Anstatt es zu killen, ja schön
Gut zu wissen jetzt wo ich es kaputt gemacht habe
Geh kaputt, geh kaputt
Kaputt gehen
Die Turrets sind schon
Dezent nervig
Wie in Battlefield
Ist nicht euer Ernst, dass der komische Turret mich auf 29% runterballert?
Wir brauchen den Schneiber
Und den Schneiber, beste
Zack, der Schneiber kann nicht schief gehen
Da ist er
Rechts, links, rechts
Rechts ist links
Aha
Das ist bestimmt ein Booster
Also wir spielen schon
Auf einem hohen Schwierigkeitsgrad
Man könnte theoretisch noch ein bisschen schwerer spielen
Ja
Machen wir aber nicht, wir wollen das Leben nicht unnötig schwer machen
Wo genau sind wir jetzt rausgekommen?
Warum ist das Leveldesign so kompliziert
Weil man überhaupt nicht checkt wo man ist
Hier waren wir schon, ne?
Waren wir hier schon?
Leute, sagt mir mal, waren wir hier schon?
Ich blicke da mal durch
Ach, das sind die ganzen Luftschächte
Die sind dafür da, dass man die Turrets umgehen kann
Jetzt habe ich das kapiert
Ich bin ja auch der Obernoob
Vier Stunden bin ich schon am Start
Krass
Hello
Was geht?
Aha
Jetzt müssen wir Kakao
Kakao nochmal platt machen
Das Ding braucht vier Saariffen
Wenn ich das richtig gezählt habe vorher
Ja
Easy
Hör nicht auf
Hier kommen wir gerade her
Hier geht es nicht lang
Kakao noch versucht abzuhauen
Passt nicht rein
Heißt in diesem Gang kommt jetzt ein neuer?
Ja
Au
Storytime
Oh
Hier geht es nicht weiter
Warum brauchen wir denn unbedingt so ein Luftschachtstellenslevel?
Ha
Jetzt kann er hier hin schießen
Das Ding
Wa
Und
Okay
Jetzt müssen wir noch gleich mal haben
Klickt irgendjemand bei dem Leveldesign gerade durch?
Fuck
Was geht jetzt?
Das ist mega verwirrend
Aha
Checkpoint
Wir sind richtig
Okay
Bam
Next please
Und
Oh ein Booster sehr nice
Get flicked
Kurz gucken ob die noch irgendwie Waffen zum Befällen dabei haben
Ah
Jetzt geht es hier weiter interessant
Komm her
Was machen die Gegner bitte für einen Damage?
Die werden jetzt geniedelt
Bam
Needle in your face
Needle
Bulletphysik
Immersion
Sag mal
Schrollen
Oh
Sag der denn die Gegner waren
Ich darf das ich bin ja auch der Spieler
So
Hier war es hier war es
Nope
Rüstung sehr fein
Rüstung
Nope
Okay wir müssen den Knopf drücken
Was denn das?
Ein Raketenwerfer
Okay was tauschen wir aus?
Also Needler und Shotgun behalten wir auf jeden Fall
Das komische Sniper Ding nehmen wir doch nie oder?
Sniper ist low
Sniper brauchen wir nicht
Wir tauschen Sniper aus
Die Musik im Hintergrund
Was passiert gerade?
Was?
Hello
Oh
Oh was ist das?
Ach du Scheiße
Über Bande
Alter
Geh weg
MonkaS
Wie wechseln wir Granaten durch?
Okay jetzt machen wir was
Krieg 17
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie Titanfall Mac oder?
Bloß in klein
Bis dann Mr. Harobo
Harobo
Kompliziert
Grünes Licht
Gleich da muss ich lang
Ach
Wisst ihr was mir gerade einfällt?
Das weiß ich auch
Ich bin auch dumm
Manchmal ist wirklich hoffentlich alles verloren bei mir
Deswegen habe ich den Raketenwerfer bekommen
Um den zu bashen
Aber natürlich habe ich ihn gebashed
Ohne Raketenwerfer
Big Brain
Massive Brain
Würde ich fast schon
mich
Hinreißen lassen
Dass das Brain nicht nur big ist
Aber auch fast huge
Mein Hintern ist eingeschlafen
Wartet mal
Alter
Oh fuck ey
Au
Ich muss mal kurz ein Stückchen stehen
Ah
Ja gut
Bumm bumm bumm
So Reifen
Na wenn schon behalten wir den Raketenwerfer jetzt auch mal kurz
Also wenn wir den jetzt schon nicht beim Boss gegen den Raketenwerfer verbraucht haben
Können wir uns den Raketenwerfer auch mal aufheben
Spielst du schon den ganzen Tag 4?
Ja
Mehr oder weniger
Also auf jeden Fall die ganzen Streamer
So für irgendwie 4,5 Stunden oder so
Guck mal da oben, da oben geht es lang
Leiter stellts
Alter
Warum ist das so du, Stavi?
Da fällt man doch runter
Kann mir doch keiner erzählen
Auf wie Half-Life Headcrabs
Oder fällt man doch nicht runter
OK
Hier irgendwas
Bam Bam
Toxic Substance aber erstmal die Luftschächte abcrawlen
Oh was denn das
Jetzt wirds aber kompliziert was ich langsam nehmen soll
Wir haben einmal den Raketenwerfer zur Auswahl
Und ein, oh das ist die Schneiber
Das ist die geile Schneiber
Die One-Hit Gegner
Die nehmen wir mit
Scheiß auf Raketenwerfer
Die Schneiber
Die Schneiber ist das Beste im Game
Das Ding das ist echt nice
Ja das stimmt
Irvoli
Mir fällt auch wenig Games ein die
Leiter klettern animiert haben
So duster
Ich hab das Gefühl hier gehts nicht lang oder
Ach wir sind wieder in der gleichen Stelle
Mein Gott ist das
Alter Game Please
Level Design auf Du
Findest du da nichts
Ah Booster
Storytime
Und Tschüss
Irvoli das
Ist aber nicht nett jetzt
Das Game will das den Rocket Launcher mitnehmen
Wer weiß
So gleich muss ich hier raus sein
Ich kann das Level nicht mehr sehen
So
Der Penetrator
Der Penetrated
Oh nice
Sentry Gun
Schreckt
Ich glaub da kommt nichts mehr
Okay
Gut
Geh ich das
Shut up
Splatter
Wo ist er
Einer müß noch da sein
Das war's
Hallo
Wir leisten Tyler Please
Ich glaub jetzt ist das Level endlich fertig
Yes
Wo ist was
Warum fetzen die eigentlich komplett auseinander
Wenn ich ihn auf den Kopf schieße
Da ist genagelt
Weiter genagelt
Rüstung
Perfekt
Shotgun
Tja
Da muss er ja durchdrehen
Level vorbei
Gott sei Dank
Geht gleich schon weiter
Hallo
Debated
Ein Booster den brauchen wir
Einfach 2005 sieht das Game wirklich nice aus
Booster
Story
Watt
Warum seh ich die MonkaS
Denn MonkaS meine ich nicht
Weil du wahrscheinlich kein FrankerFacesZ
Oder BelletWitchTV drauf hast
Lass mich raus
Was auch immer
Gut, dass ich immer Health Packs einsammle
Achtung
Bam
Das Platters
Ich seh dich
Die Säule
Alter
Gehts den Nehmen lang
Wieder Granate
Rüstung
Was ist das hier
Beste
Soll ich mal der komplette Settingwechsel aufgefallen von diesem Level zum letzten Level
Granate
In US
Stimmt Raketenwerfer
Der muss mit dem Raketenwerfer gehaunt werden
Ich hab keinen Raketenwerfer mehr
Wir können das neue Sniper Gewehr ausprobieren
Schreckt
Ich glaube aber der Evoli hat gar nicht gebaitet
Der hat gedacht ich hab den Raketenwerfer noch
Was ich auch geglaubt hab
Jetzt werden sie gereckt
Das geht in jedem Shooter
Einfach oben warten bis die Gegner kommen
Die Jäger sind halt nicht so doof wie man sich das vorstellt
An die Wand genagelt
Shotgun
Was ist hier los
Storytime
Schreien die hier rum
Das ist auch auf der einen Seite cleverer Gegner und auf der anderen Seite wird rumgespielt
Überbande
Die hat es krass zerrissen gerade
Die hat es ordentlich zerrissen gerade
Schreien die hier rum
Storytime
Lauf